[Music]
we're just gonna do a quick check-in
okay let's do a check-in check in with
me you tell i'm waiting on pat we are
rolling okay
pop pop
my brain just shut down
bab
stop
oh you are
there's no that's a listening exercise
zip zop is an actor are you guys
listening i
not anymore they weren't so you guys
brought a nerdy ass acting game into it
jesus christ
these are a bunch of theater geeks guys
i apologize
the fact that neither of you have only
fans is truly the most embarrassing
thing that has ever happened to me
i know they're in it for the art and the
craft
but i just want to dance what i really
this is me in the pictures i know that
the day these two quit there it's gonna
be like look i love it here i just
really wanna dance
i really wanna dance and i'm like doing
this interpretive i'm like so what are
you doing you're on okay so it's a
cruise
no it's a van okay
we go to like high schools around the
country yes the high schools around the
country a couple other comedians did
that didn't work out so well so what are
you doing you're going to va okay so
you're doing an interpretive dance at i
didn't realize little fair was still on
i know don't you know what do not use my
stutters again that is actually too low
of a blow when i my mouth moves i'm
sorry
my brain
yes it moves faster than my brain and it
happens a lot and i'm not sorry for it
you don't apologize it's my new brain
by the way if my new thing double down
double down if i apologize to somebody
just out of a
i'm sorry for my existence and they
accept it i will take it back wait yeah
so how about this so apologize to me
just because you
visited me so i ran into you and you
apologize right
sorry oh no you're good
um no
actually
how dare you
that was not an apology for you that was
just some internalized ancestral trauma
and self-loathing i wasn't really sorry
yeah i am good actually
so
but i feel we're sometimes when they're
like you don't need to apologize for
that like just don't acknowledge it yeah
yeah just ignore me like my parents did
jesus christ just like this isn't about
you
yeah i hate it with that is even more
annoying when someone feels the need to
like brene brown me yeah at the airport
when you're like sorry and they're like
don't apologize you've done nothing
wrong i'm like
i know yeah yeah yeah yeah keep walking
common courtesy
there's a difference yeah there's no
over apologizing sexual harassment i can
deal with
mental
harassment where i need to like myself
more in this moment right that's a whole
other thing yeah i'm not i'm not at my
best right now right i'm on autopilot
right right right you don't get my best
no you get a i'm sorry all the time yeah
what's in it for you uh-huh right yeah
who are you fucking
what's his name you're by the way
you're in a middle c
you've got the daily stoic next to me on
the airplane right here i'm really big
now on if i hear a piece of wisdom i
need to know who said it right it does
not matter unless the person that said
it like
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
did christopher reeve say it right right
or did hitler
okay so i just thought we'd do a quick
high catch up because i've been gone for
months six months i've been gone for a
while years years i haven't seen anyone
um i've been gone so long my hair's
brown
naturally just fully grown out
um and uh i came back with uh some new
stones oh yeah
congratulations such a johnny depp style
oh oh so we are gonna do a full
download i wouldn't even call it i would
call it half um
reenactment oh wait okay i get to be
amber it's like two people that struggle
with mental demons emotional demons who
were too shit-faced to remember anything
neither of them remember what happened
but once you
say what you think happened in the court
of law you have to double down or else
it's perjury which is why we never make
permanent decisions based on temporary
feelings
who said that i just i hate hitler
that one was for sure by the way yeah it
would have ended ultimately he didn't
take i was gonna say yeah in
the group hall of fame of someone that
made permanent decisions based on
temporary feelings
um and so um it's really important to
get into
we go they're both guilty
having been in a relationship like that
before i feel like i know exactly do you
want to tell everyone what you tried to
do while you were in dc
oh i tried to go to the case i tried to
go live uh i just would have loved i was
in
virginia oh my god i was like i was like
what's up because i am obsessed with the
fact that she now dresses like
sinbad
why is she in a three-piece suit why
does she have a like a cummerbund it's
also amazing because they both dress
exactly the same yeah they are still i'm
like you guys are still in love your
soul mates like i'm sorry i will there
won't they like i don't think that's
paying attention they're both the only
two people that have like cummerbunds on
anywhere
it's like
like it's so funny because you can't
make it work because he won't look at
her and it's just so funny to me that if
he does catch a glance he's like is that
my camera
like you should look at her just to see
how she's dressed because it is wild
dude
she's wearing your three
boyfriend she's wearing your outfit if
you saw her you'd be like wait a second
maybe we should be together we both
dress like lemonade snickers
it's the fact that her body is now she's
like full live at the apollo and then
her hair is like amish rumps bring up
like they're trying to make her look
like a mentalist how many that is the
most french braids i have seen since i
played against basketball under the
banner of heaven that morning but but i
do think that they're all the
psychological decisions and if you are
going to court what do i wear
right i'm just obsessed with all of
those like
101 yeah
dude forget what's at stake forget what
the accusations are because i think that
ship has sailed i also
do strongly believe
if
okay let's say they're both victims of
emotional and physical abuse i think
they both did it to each other okay this
is what it seems like to me i can't tell
you the severity on the fact i think
they could tell you the severity of it
at this point it's a complete worship
test of do you
want to sort of like
allow women to behave however they want
and still be a victim always and do you
want like how many lies do we want to
tell ourselves and how equal do we want
women to be if we go like oh
they're equal in every way they should
be able to have their finger on the nuke
button as a president
but they're incapable of abusing someone
else so they're obviously not that
powerful sure so if me saying you're a
piece of shit you're a joke
doesn't matter then i must be unequal
right right right
in any way so which is it are we made of
glass only powerful which we have to
decide you know so
i think that's why it's so fascinating
to me but yeah watching people try to
figure out um
how yachts are designed is hilarious to
me watching everyone try to figure out
what the biggest threat of perjury right
now is that he had four penthouses in
downtown all of our friends were living
in them and the big question is where
was this taken
penthouse two and they're like
they're trying to remember which
penthouse they're in i'm like is this
she's like i think that's penthouse
2.
like it is what is happening and then
also the fact that the jury has to get
into the mind of these rich people that
are completely off the grid yeah yeah
they're like okay he flew in right
ten bottles of this malbec that's sixty
thousand dollars a bottle right and then
we get them all back and it's this whole
thing and he has to have this one mall
back and you're like oh what an asshole
he's yeah right all right it's all it's
all working it's working um even though
none of that should really matter none
of that's abused technically you're just
trying to make me not like him right and
then it's like well then he threw the
wine bottle i'm like do you expect me to
believe that the same guy that flew the
wine bottle right
is going to break that same wine bottle
yeah that said and then you have to put
yourself in the shoes of someone that
would order a 60 right right
and put it on a private jet i don't
think that person would throw it but
maybe he's that self-destruct i don't
it's like people kill their dudes
sometimes i mean you made that
grace why sent ladies and gentlemen
okay
the wheels they are save some of this
for our actual discussion about it i
want you guys this is the kind of
classic good for you granular thinking
you're going to go to which is we like
to look at context clues we don't like
to look at the obvious shit everyone
else is doing he's guilty she's guilty i
like to look at like the minutia two
things can be true at once and let's
look at let's look at why
we want to jump to that oh he's guilty
and it's like okay why did i just think
that what internalized sexism ancestral
trauma right trauma why do i want to
believe that also
the crowd the tar and feathering of her
also is like what's like underlying
misogyny
that we all immediately amber turd it's
like
that's not a good reflection no one
called her that till
right there was some evidence that she
in the bed
if your last name rhymes with turd and
you poop in a bed as someone with the
last name cummings do you know how hard
i've worked to never come
i don't think you've tried that hard i
think you just haven't because if i did
i'd be in a jam yeah i'm just i think
that
can we just can you share your mom's
last name for everyone i was suggesting
we just i don't know if we can get this
but i just don't think enough people
mom's last name is coming
no s and next time someone wants to
bully me for anything and then she
married someone who comes with the net
and then they decided
[Laughter]
after they
decided mean they decided to pay less
taxes like the way that you paid this
whole thing you're welcome i do remember
yeah my parents got divorced i remember
because you kind of are like forced to
pick sides because that's a healthy
thing to make kids do at that age and i
remember being like my dad's last name
is cummings and my mom's is coming
mm-hmm like which is worse on the school
yard coming is the verb yeah yeah yeah
well you made you picked smart yeah my
mom was paddy cumming coming
all right i just want it over i don't
think enough people miraculous
so yeah okay really quick a couple
little
thoughts and then we have to get out of
here because i just i haven't done i
haven't seen you guys in so long and i
haven't caught up with everyone i just
want you to know i have been watching
the trial for eight hours straight yeah
this can't get in touch with her because
she's watching no i am if you text me
you are taking
you're stealing my life you're stealing
me from johnny and amber they need me
and i do i just think it's very
important that
johnny had a there's this is what drives
me nuts when crazy shit happens and no
one says anything that is my main be in
my bonnet that's my lot in life when
there's an elephant in the living room
and no one says anything about it i am
the person that's like hey you know that
thing everyone noticed when no one
talked about yeah that's my anti-wasp
bread and butter come hear me talk about
that for three hours um
in a jean jacket with my name on it um
so
johnny depp has a witness first of all
60 of the witnesses are vaping during
their testimony which is their right
fine as americans but like you one you
couldn't take a dick did you see that
the main witness for uh uh one of the
main witnesses i believe it was for i
don't know he was like a talent agent
who represented them had a liechtenstein
of a hot blonde oh yeah behind him yeah
and you're just like is anyone looking
at the background of their zoom this is
the court of law this is a high law it's
just so funny to me the number of john
varvatos scarves on these men so there's
this one guy who's johnny depp's like
best friend from high school maybe and
he's like the super like tough guy and
you're like i know exactly what i'm
about to see right this is his turtle
this is his next turtle this is some guy
from boston who comes in and you know
whatever i never saw or witnessed
whatever type of claim
that is that is being said
ever but you have seen mr debt
use drugs as well as drink and be drunk
correct
oh yeah okay
and you're like okay love this guy you
know this is his salt of the earth best
friend his nick curse on if you will yes
yeah and he's already like a little
emotional and you're like oh my god this
is like i get what this scene is right
right because this is just one big it's
a we're watching this we're watching and
acting off this is the olympics of
acting oh that's whoever wins is it's
just like may the best actor win right
yeah because they're that's it they're
both in the chat acting championships
yeah yeah you know like it's tricky this
is also a man that you know
made us believe that lie professionally
i thought he had scissors for hands
until like a couple of years ago very
convincing and they're all okay
i mean we're all like look at johnny
poor guy it's like no he played someone
with down syndrome he doesn't have it in
real life more like oh this poor guy i'm
just like obsessed with the way we do
both and we're like that amber she loves
to fuck it's like no she did a couple
movies where she played that yeah yeah
just like looking at the ways that their
acting has influenced the way that we
see them as people right um where am i
going with this okay so this guy
is on the stand right and he's um uh
he's like you know look and it was so
sincere and he's like both of you like i
just want the best for you johnny i've
known you forever like i love you man
like just please like this has been so
hard on everyone just go your separate
ways like amber i want you to like have
your life and i want you to have your
life and like it's been so hard on me
and like on me i can't even paint
anymore
so good
what why time out slow down
pause
the
whoa whoa whoa
where are the paintings this okay i need
a
i need a handle i need an etsy store
george w bush
it's george w bush's dog room this guy
can't paint
oh those are the best kind of painters
the verdict is in you're both fucking
monsters you ruined this man's painting
career like the fact
that i'm like where do i buy these i'm
online looking for his paintings and
this feels like a local farmer's market
situation
this is like jane seymour situation
where she kind of started and then tell
anyone i can't get enough of it the shit
that's just like thrown in casually and
how every time they tell a story someone
loses their job
and they don't give a fuck it's so
wild so every time they tell a story to
try to throw the other rich person under
the bus another person that either works
for them i'm not a rich person right
hotel in a random country loses their
job yeah so she's like yeah we're on the
plane and we're
he does eight pills of molly i do a
bunch of molly we talk the flight
attendant in to doing molly with us i'm
like well she's fired now
and they're like that we land in russia
the manager of saint regis russia sees
her him hit me i'm like no yeah
[Applause]
they just keep getting dominance
and then they'll tell a different
version of the story and then they're
like yeah well then the concierge of the
state region saw you hit me and yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the one with the huge scar on his face
can you let the people getting paid a
hundred grand a year keep their
jobs jesus
like this is a hundred grand a year oh
and then within
that you see all the other people that
are taking advantage of johnny depp and
it makes you feel bad for johnny yeah
but no one thinks about that so it's
like there was like a they had a fight
and they brought in like i guess the
maintenance team and they're to say like
how extensive was the damage and they're
like it was really bad and he was like
what happened oh he threw two bottles of
wine around or there were two bottles of
wine that's what we found the detritus
everywhere
stains on the carpet and they're like
how much damage your product
that you have for me i is i love that
you just worked the word detritus into
like such a casual like this is where i
shine i i i i just haven't seen you this
fired up about something in a very long
time okay so the
person is talking i know i don't know
i'm meant to be a lawyer and i just
don't have time to go to law school and
i think most laws are so stupid that i
can't but i do think i should just be
a jury like just me master class
teachers basically 12 people
from different walks of life it's true
i'm basically a jury in one yeah i
believe because i can argue every point
and i actually that was such a good
insight into your psychology yeah i'm
like 12 people that need 50
who bucks know enough about the news to
be biased about a trial
just stupid or not like you're smiling
yeah wait what was the thing i was
saying about that i'm sorry so the
detritus they threw the wine the two
bottles of wine so there they they have
the expert like the cleaning crew yeah
who's saying this is what we saw and
they're like how much did it cost and he
was like seventy-five thousand dollars
and you're like
well this fucking guy should get sued
right now right now this guy sidebar he
this guy's definitely fucking you over
yeah we're we're not sure about her yet
but you see all these other people that
are taking advantage of him it's like
and no one questions it right yeah yeah
yeah two bottles seventy five thousand
dollars yeah i had to clean that shit
for ten grand
[Laughter]
i'm like there is a big racket and just
dm'ing johnny does being like hey like i
know you're yeah i have a lot on your
plate right now
but i
would love to clean your home for 40
grand a day yeah i'd like to be your
cork collector i can cut what you're
paying in half right now absolutely 40
grand
again yeah yeah yeah the number of
people that are fucking him over it is
so crazy and sad
yeah
and then the number of people okay last
thing the number of people not taking
sides the number of her witnesses
of whom all are estranged from her which
is you know it happens side note side
note
all of them so far have plugged their
business
in their testimony one to got a
fabfitfun box
she's using her charcoal toothpaste
brand she's like slowly flipping up a
thing that's like betterhelp.com whitney
she's just like
they're like well as i said i'm on my
new podcast now available on all the
stitchers
whose name changes every time it was
rocky and now it's raquel
like okay um and uh uh it's rocky when
you're at coachella but it's raquel when
you're in a lot when you're on the stand
yeah yeah exactly and so um uh she's
talking about okay so
watching her be torn by how annoyed she
was to have to make this testimony and
how sad she was about her friend's
relationship but how psyched she was to
talk about her necklace company so many
emotions because she's like
he's like yeah so after they got in a
fight she's like yeah i mean i left
because i had to go prepare i had a big
show the next day um in santa monica for
my bead beading
it was like probably two one two ocean
crafting fair and they're like i had to
get ready for the crafting fair and then
one of the photos and evidence i guess
johnny had knocked over her necklaces
from her crafting fair and they showed
photos of and they're like what do you
see her and she's like those are my
necklaces
and
i'm not saying he didn't violently knock
them over and do something terrible but
i can see myself sober knocking
that display
in this one case we are choosing a size
in this one case i agree with johnny
those necklaces should have been on the
floor
where they belong because her parents
trust fund did not deserve to have to
pay for this fake business
and then her husband who they've now
broken up
uh he go he was there the night of the
birthday dinner
this entire thing is about her birthday
dinner right i have not been following
this you better get it yeah i'm going
i'm about to spend yeah yeah no no no no
no no i'd rather i'd rather i'm gonna go
in blind it's here's the thing
it really he was late
the major issue is that
he was two hours late to something in
l.a
it's like people are like he was late to
your birthday
yeah it was downtown like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it it was downtown on a
friday night yeah
the day before coachella which if you
live in l.a you know how ridiculous this
is right because everyone leaves for
coachella the night before it's like
alcohol abuse whatever everyone is two
hours late to everything on a friday no
matter what yeah yeah but it was her
30th birthday so she's like they're
they're like she's the girl camille was
like um so you were pretty upset that he
was late to your birthday dinner she was
like yeah it mattered a lot to me and he
was late
and they were like uh oh but wasn't he
at a meeting did he have a meeting with
the business manager and she goes
oh my god i'm so obsessed with this um
she goes uh well yeah he told me he had
a meeting with his business managers uh
addicts lie a lot like she's just done
she's done she's done and like wait so
you're saying he wasn't there or he what
you're saying he was somewhere else and
she goes everything he tells me i just
take with a thick grain of addict salt
no oh it's gone dude everyone's done did
you see her lawyer give up did aaron
sorkin write that yeah by the way feels
like it but i'm on no one's side every
minute you're on a different perspective
right
it is completely all of it is about our
egos and our own projections and it's a
perfect rorschach test of two assholes
and we see ourselves in both of them and
it's like so painful to watch and like
but um but yeah it's just it's off the
grid i don't know why i was bringing
that up there was something more
important about uh oh so the guy that's
going to coachella with them
so he's there and he's testifying for
her and he was like so you were at this
30th this 30th birthday is a big deal if
you guys don't know about it 10 hours
three it's a whole thing
he was late um and uh he did text her
telling her he'd be late mm-hmm
not taking sides
but also you realize
we have proof that he texted you right
right he may have texted me at some
point i don't know
it might not have been him oh one of his
bodyguards could have texted me wasn't
necessarily him that's what i say when
you text me there's no
there's no
way she's gonna get me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah to commit right yeah yeah yeah
to anything right right it's a free
genius she's a mad genius yeah so she'll
go they're like ma'am uh uh
miss her did you donate the 3.5 million
dollars to the aclu i pledged it oh yes
did you donate it yeah yeah i played
everyone's treating communication how
much they love her
um and then uh uh
no it's like buying a house you don't
pay for all of it in full well that's
why we had a mortgage crisis in canada
they do pay you don't buy a house you
can't afford like that's actually not
anyone can say like i'll donate at some
point yeah and then she goes
i've pledged 755 million to the yeah
where's my brick some guy pledged
seventy five hundred dollars so emily
for the wedgie video that doesn't come
through yeah
after she posted a photo with her
boyfriend can't wait for that trial back
i feel like we named the puppy a little
too soon um as someone who's famous for
naming puppies too soon
all right we're gonna have nothing left
to talk about on the actual day of the
week oh no
this is just last thing okay no so her
husband wait you mean necklace husband
off the 30th birthday oh yeah they're
like were you there on the 30th birthday
and he goes yes i was there uh i catered
it
with my catering company
johnny's catering
but mitzvah's weddings like it is oh my
god wild
yeah i mean every single oh dude no turn
you didn't see the one oh where amber
heard's um lawyer gave up halfway
through oh no i saw that she goes i'm
trying
was there
yes yes she was like what zip zap's not
what do i throw you
what can i allow you to go into one of
your monologues yeah what do you mean me
to do say something from talented mr
ripley like how like what do i do talk
about meadow she didn't
it's just watching everyone lose their
minds laura wasser oh
mvp of the good for you podcast she i i
hope she doesn't get mad i'm bringing
her up on it but uh about this she goes
um
all these lawyers know each other mm-hmm
it's like comedians and podcasters yeah
and then
elaine uh amber's lawyer asked her a
question she's like elaine you know i
can't answer that
it's all just like elaine you know i
can't do that like they're all snow each
other so well and this whole rigmarole
is just so ridiculous you're like
elaine yeah
can't answer that yeah yeah obviously i
don't know that like it's just so funny
to watch all these people just be like i
want to be as far as fucking away as
possible from this shit show oh the one
thing i will say really quick
the confusion about why this is
happening sh
i think that there's a and this was a
lesson for me too because i think that
this whole we but i didn't name him
whether he's a criminal or not abused
you're not right right right right right
i'm gonna stay out of that because i
don't know yet i personally i personally
i'm a very conflicted juror i need to i
need to see more evidence i really do
whitney's like i want this child to go
on for years oh my god i will uh i have
so much uh the fact that i am still on
the i mean i am just it's a nail biter
i am on the edge of my seat because it
is so much more fun
it's not fun if someone's you know
getting abused but it is so much more
interesting to not
have a foregone conclusion because your
ego already has an opinion because you
want to be right i'm like i want to be
wrong i want to be wrong and i just want
to like right i want to it's a clue who
done it yeah yeah and so ann this is
what is so fascinating i think to me and
i can say fascinating not like
entertaining but like right abuse is
this complicated
it's this hard to understand yeah when
you hear about it or when someone tries
to speak up about it and you're like
it's so hard to believe that this is
happening but it's happening and it's
also just such a chicken in the egg it's
like is the manipulation first is the
abuse first like where did it originate
who started it like you can never know
those things yeah is abuse just a smack
in the face or is it like years you know
but and if you've stayed or you are
participating are you lying about it
just because you stayed yeah that being
said there are some very black and white
cases of abuse like you don't mean but
this is not one of them right this is a
very
and by the way the kind of people that
you know sign up to be famous which i'm
sorry to be famous you have to work
really hard at it and there's an engine
a wound that is driving it
you know
and
to fill that wound you will resort to
all kinds of things and i think that as
you become more and more famous infamy
that's when it you can decide okay is
infamy just as good as fame and i've
seen people that are fine with infamy
and those people are really dangerous
and people that legitimately were harmed
in the past right might feel like
they're being harmed in the present but
they're actually not but it's hard to
take that away from them because you
legitimately are a victim so the going
you know the woman that was talking
about borderline personality disorder
and histonic personality disorder i
think there was so much sexism with her
because i think they thought she was
pretty yeah and people didn't like it
yeah like i'm more interested in our
reaction to all of the witnesses and how
we discredit them based on the fact that
they're pretty what they're wearing i
think it's just like helpful to
face your prejudices like that's what's
happening where i go like oh this
woman's probably full of shit and i'm
like
right right that you just thought that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah because she's pretty i'm jealous
right right right what the fuck like i
think that this is a great opportunity
to do that you know it's like a
rorschach test yeah totally or i'll see
someone's wearing a fancy suit i'm like
well why is he overcompensating right
why would you wear you don't and they're
like what he's going to core yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying just like the
things that you tell yourself in order
to um uh get an easy resolution right or
just noticing your initial programming
yeah totally you know what i mean did
you see the part where um they asked
johnny can i just play this really quick
please oh my nose just really quick
by thursday it'll be like our new open
okay so they are asking johnny depp
about um
what he thinks
uh about like a picture yeah and
it was they're trying to like paint him
as a drug addict which means whatever is
isn't that's not my place it's a
self-diagnosed disease you guys um but
this is a video of them pushing him
about a photo that has like white powder
ready
you tell them that you have no food for
days
powders which is cocaine right
right sure
sure
you fucking dork yeah yeah i'm fucking
johnny depp
that's like that well that bog could fit
a lot of cocaine that remember that line
no they were like they're like is this a
cocaine box he's like no but it could be
i don't know use your eyes i need i mean
it's just like
yeah
when you're in that place where you're
able to make jokes and you're like he
was fishing around my pussy for cocaine
it's like you don't think johnny depp
hat knows where his fucking blow is yeah
yeah you think he doesn't have nine
fucking antique
horn boxes
that were given to him
by fucking scott whalen
full of cocaine
yeah you're trying to tell me that he
doesn't have a fucking
custom
treasure trove from the war field yeah
he doesn't have the necklace from cruel
intentions
you're trying to tell me that next to
kurt cobain's guitar
he doesn't have a satchel given to him
by that aerosmith guy
slash or whatever
full
chock full
i do not believe the same pussy that's
getting elon musk and johnny depp and
all these men is big enough to fit more
than two fingers
that's just kind of cocaine and the bag
is not getting a little they're small
but you think johnny depp's gonna date
someone who can fit more than two
fingers in her hand
[Laughter]
i rest
if you just went do you really think i
would date someone who if i thought
their pussy could hold more than two
lines of cocaine
i'm johnny depp you guys
oh my god god that's not funny
anyway all right well do you want
defense rest yeah the defense rests and
we won and if i'm not here for the rest
of the week i will be flying to fairfax
virginia right i am colluding with a
couple friends about going
to get you have to okay so you can pay
someone to wait at three in the morning
we have people near there that could do
it what about your knees
send your niece
that's a great idea could does she ever
drive a harder bargain than thirty grand
she's cute people are charging thirty
three thousand dollars oh i'll go do
this might be for the verdict by the way
oh okay i do yeah i'm gonna go who needs
me to stand in line let me ask
my uncle who's a lawyer and you how do
we go
i mean would it be really weird if you
were just gonna call me in an incredible
i mean it must be the only one
how's her focus she definitely needs it
i love my uncle more than anything but
he is such an uncle and i finally have
like a parental figure and it's so
hilarious how
much they need to send back a charger
that you left them i have more like
calls in my call log from your uncle
than i do from anybody in my own vlog to
the cummings family i love it i'm asking
for flight details like hey by the way i
got the car washed
just like let her know
and now you're going to hear a brilliant
brilliant neuroscientist and professor
of business in an interview where we
talk all things neuroscience you know me
um
challenging uh scientists love to do it
no one ever has the balls to do it
except this guy that's not going to age
well um and uh he's so brilliant also
moren he used to be a hacker i know a
white hat hacker which meant i had to
it's never too late to forgive he was a
one he was a hacker for good like he'd
hack something and be like
this needs things hey i got your news
yeah yeah yeah yeah here they are i'm
returning them yeah
so
um
it's so good my face the entire time was
like this
fascinated he is so fascinating he is so
brilliant you are going to love moron
surf excuse me being like nervous and
frazzled i get a little nervous and
frazzled around neuroscientists
it's moran surf yeah i thought you just
said moron
remember when i made a movie called uh
the female brains
brian
no by the way ever since my so-called
life when uh
jared leto's character
red
brain
off of a thing that says brian yeah
that's my favorite shit ever uh also
house inhabit has some highlights on
jared leno that are sketchy
uh anyway just throwing grenades um
what's that one my brain is not working
my so-called life before
just say his name again for me
moron surf
morale
more
answer i enjoy the time you have to get
on this couch and just say morons just
say
remember oh remember when i remember
when i did a uh movie called the female
brain uh written by luanne brisendine
and i said the name wrong the entire
movie
and had to go in and adr it yeah so
that's what i'm trying to save myself
tonight so just say moran moran surf
[Music]
we're starting the podcast introduce
yourself because i'm going to screw it
up i am moron surf and i'm a professor
of neuroscience and business there's a
couple
um
issues that i feel like
neuroscientists are uniquely qualified
to answer that just we're not hearing
from in terms of like the phone stuff
the social media stuff
um
and i just think everyone really wants
like a real answer about that query more
about your
space okay have more questions
you know what i have so much shame about
all this stuff but i love this but it
was like the idea is like this is going
to be the weird like pee-wee's playhouse
room where everything that fans have
made or given
i'm just going to put up
and they've made legos ever they're
behind you yeah like just things where
you're like ugh this is like the
narcissist
shit show but then again people love to
see their stuff like so many people
write in when they see something that
was theirs like we made it yeah it's
like it's like f like i don't know it's
like stuff that either influenced me as
a child or just stuff that i kind of
love or
you know i don't know it's a it's a good
like creative space let's pick one tell
me about the
uh this is whitney's brain are we yeah
this is literally the inside of my brain
okay is
this actually is
this you're about to
really walk into a dark alley right now
let's go there
because
as i said i was like oh this is all
stuff that fans have sent
uh
you just busted me in a lie because
i definitely my thing is like fans have
sent this stuff this is stuff that was
given to us for the podcast and i'm just
like putting it out to like celebrate
all the fans and like the things people
have made i
you pointed out the one thing i recently
purchased
and i'm trying to pass it off as if
someone sent it because i'm too ashamed
to admit that i recently bought a
faberge egg so how about which is the
wildest purchase
the cr like i'm supporting russia right
now
like as
i am pro i'm like here's my favorite i
just bought this like two weeks ago
because i did um i was studying this
woman marjorie post who she's who
invented the pop tart and stuff like
that and she was comes from the post
family and she married a russian czar
she married uh the ambassador to russia
and she collected faberge eggs and i'm
just obsessed with wild-ass people like
i get in wormholes of just eccentric
people like i mean i google
isadora duncan's death by her scarf like
a couple times a week like i just
love weird shit and weird people so this
is a faberge egg and i just thought it
was really
something yeah there was a full story
you walked in the street and you saw it
you went looking for it i can't believe
it yeah no i well you're
now it's even worse because yeah no i
just googled
how do i literally i believe the google
search was cheapest faberge egg
and then i went on ebay and here's the
great thing about ebay etsy you're
supporting someone that's in a jam you
know what i'm saying you're all you're
getting the thing you want which is a
fabric egg which i would never pay full
price for but like some a divorce went
really sideways like some criminal
stole this like i mean there's no way
it's real it doesn't now it doesn't say
faberge anywhere now i'm realizing this
has just made it like color me mine and
st louis but
um i was just like i want one of those
like i was that's such a stupid thing to
collect like eggs that are sparkly and
then i saw it i was like i've gotta have
one of those
like look how meaningful it is right now
now it's the one thing that all the
friends are looking at like you're gonna
get five after this show
because but it's also like i think
after the pandemic i think or just i'm i
can't wait to talk to you about like the
neurological psychological brain effects
of this the fact that i am talking in
the most interesting person on the
planet is here and i'm talking about a
fucking my hoarding my egg hoarding
addiction maybe it's because i have less
eggs in my uterus these days i need to
collect eggs i don't there's something
subconscious about it but i am obsessed
with the things that you thought were
dumb
as like
in your
before and now you're like i can't live
without this like i used to think it was
so dumb to collect sparkly shiny shit
that had no purpose and now i'm like
i now that i've won i i can't see the
point of living until i get like 30 more
two weeks ago i got it
yeah it's pretty recent so here's a game
to play so there's a colleague of mine
who's a professor at austin
sam gosling here's a book called snoop
and it's all about you walk into
someone's room they're not there you
start looking around try to figure out
who they are oh i this is what i did
this is how i became a writer
growing up i because i was alone all the
time and i would see people and i would
try to tell figure their story out and
then i would like i'd see them in a
grocery store and i'd be like okay this
person is divorced in history and then i
go up to them i go do you have three kit
that i was like would ask them then see
if i was close and i'm usually pretty
close so let's do it for you so we go
look in this room let's see let's see
what to make out of it horses i get the
horses you get yeah
the egg we now know
who's in the picture the frame one
this is
michael patrick king who uh created uh
who made sex in the city created the
comeback we made a show called two broke
girls together this is me and him
pretending we're having fun on the
fourth of july but the frame it's more
for the frame it's the frame is uh
elephants and we love elephants and why
did you put this one here and why this
one of all paintings or pictures why did
i put it there um well the okay it's
kind of a
big psychological reason uh it fit
it was the only place of it
the most of the stuff that's in here
here's the darkest part honestly the
darkest part is every night i come in
here and i rearrange these but yeah
you're making me realize that i did try
to organize this in some way so this is
um the like two bro girls section also
i am really into
olfactory the power of the olfactory and
nostalgia and how to time travel
and i think i'm learning that for me
smell is one of the biggest parts
everyone it's wild smell is like one of
the most important senses that we
overlook
we don't use it enough to like prompt
our brains and change our mind state so
on the one hand it's the one that
is extremely helpful to us that we don't
really recognize is important for us the
other thing is that our noses are here
and smells are mostly here so we're kind
of like a bad animal in terms of using
the noses like i've really started to
employ that like when i need to be in a
different mood i'll wear a different
perfume like when i need to be energized
i have a little pine oil that i carry
with me like spruce or pine it just like
wakes you up and it's really intense
i've got the little menthol inhalers now
where it's just a little stick of like
menthol just whether it's
so here's a quick experiment in the
brain this guy is right no i'm sobel is
his name
brings you so you are subject in this
experiment you shop to the lab and they
tell you we're gonna do something that
has to do with understanding how you
think and so on but you show up someone
shakes your hands give you a cup of tea
has you sit down and tell you you're
gonna wait for a few minutes until we
start the experiment and you wait in
lobby and they're out the experiment
began you don't know yeah it's right
right okay but actually in the room what
they do is the monetary evaluate and
what they show is that within a few
minutes from the moment that someone
shook your hand that's the prompt most
people take their hand and do something
like this
they kind of
smell their hand and they only do it
with the mixture of the person that they
met as a way to essentially
see if they're a good match
so you kind of rub your hand onto
someone else's hand you mix the smell
and then when they're gone you smell it
without even consciously being aware of
that to tell yourself yeah we're a good
match now then they did it really nicely
in a controlled way so
if you are female and you're
heterosexual you do it when you shake
the head of a man but not with a woman
if you're a gay man it's only when
you're shaking their hand over wow
for some people they had they were
gloves so they checked their head
without a glove and then people don't do
it it's really about you
seeing if we're a good match matchmaker
and if we if someone smells bad that
means we could in some way be related in
the past in some way is also a way to
prevent inbreeding bad offsprings
something not gonna work uh we're
kind of realizing without knowing it
consciously that there's not a good
match here and we should at least
not give it a kind immediate and you
don't really know you're doing it and
then but you're not able are you able to
how does your behavior change if the if
it smells bad how did you know how did
he know that the person's behavior
changed in some way so all that they
wanted to show in this experiment is
that people do it unconsciously often so
we wanted to show that even though we
kind of think that they we don't really
rely on smells for choices it turns out
that they're subconsciously we're doing
it all the time and that they're
specifically related to somehow
mating because you do it with men
if you're a woman and you're just
actually do it with like a man if you're
a gay man like you kind of it works such
that you really look at something that's
going to be relevant to your you know
sex life can you hack
your way out of that like if you really
like someone
and their bo is like they stink in some
way can you overcome can you go i know
this is what my primordial brain is
doing i know my reptilian brain is
trying to give me some kind of pathogen
avoidance or avoid inbreeding or
whatever but like can you consciously
overcome it so first of all the ck1
thing that you showed me is kind of like
our way of doing it right we kind of
invented things to
mask things we also invented things to
mass thing that kind of screw our brain
like we have the pill right
well it's also yeah so it's like the
birth control pill it's like where it
messes up who we're attracted to because
our body thinks that we're pregnant we
smell pheromones differently when we're
on the pill right so they say that
before you if you're on the birth
control pill and you are dating someone
you should go off it right for like six
months before you make any permanent
decisions
to see if you still like them but then
how what does that break up look like
hey i love you but my body doesn't
i think it will be two step process so
you will you will not you won't even say
that like you would say somehow this guy
starts rubbing me the wrong way like i'm
not understanding him the same joke that
would work on on the pill would not work
as well after appeal and you will start
kind of narrating to yourself for
reasons that you would break up with him
for that would be partially true but
mostly driven by something else is it
it's also i talked about this at my hbo
special and of course now i'm like
forget conflating how it was isn't it
when um you're kind of more attracted to
like a uh like a lack of a better word
like a bad boy someone that has like
high risk danger alpha male when you are
on the pill because that's when you need
the most amount of protection so it
depends on your cycle in your life but
yeah there's some stage where you're
gonna definitely like the
leather jacket motorcyclist and there's
some times in your life you're gonna
like the opposite so
just know it yeah it's actually the
and the kind of person who you attract
when you're on uh because also aren't
because your body is basically pregnant
right don't you give off a different
kind of smell like aren't different
people attracted to you more because
you're pregnant there's a study i'm of
course forgetting the name of the guy
but it's basically a study of a pole
dancers so this guy went to pole dancers
is that not the right word
is that what we're saying now we can't
say strippers anymore sleepers pole
dancers funny you know where i come from
like i was raised in israel in israel
it's illegal so when i moved to the u.s
i went to a conference and for the first
time they said hey tonight's going to be
a good day to go to a sleepless i
thought everyone's going to commit a
huge crime like we're going to all go to
sleep
i ran to the hotel i said never gonna do
it took me some time to understand that
it's allowed in the u.s normally but
that is so wild because when i went to
scandinavia i went to norway uh and i
was performing and i was on the um phone
with a journalist and i remember being
like oh i'm gonna come and i'm gonna
come see the strip clubs like whatever i
don't know like i don't know and they're
like oh we don't have show clubs here
and i was like oh my god is are they
illegal and then he just went no we just
um
respect women i've never been to one
actually i was like what so what's the
pull dancers pole dancers and by the way
because also like as a professor there's
certain words like do you get sat down
like words you're allowed to say are you
we're not like say hooker anymore really
no i don't think so there's a
you have to say future ceo
funny alarming uh kind of
document that came out from i forget
where i guess
where some committee spent days
discussing words and made a list of
words you cannot say and why you cannot
say them and it's mostly kind of
being ridiculed by academics because it
has
like things that you really don't know
the story of and like i think you can't
say ladies and gentlemen anymore when
you open a class because it's like
offensive to people who are not ladies
and gentlemen this thing that used to
just mean nothing and was just polite is
now
like rude so my industry academia is
responsible for that and i apologize on
your behalf because we're the ones who
really made it extreme so you really
can't be normal and i think that normal
would be to say something figure it's
not right say apologize that's it that
should be that should be the right thing
or it's like not personal it's just a
figure of speech that's like ladies and
gentlemen like what do you want me to
say
like you know like it's just like
not a good use of a scientist's time the
list is really fun if you read this list
you kind of will will start thinking
that it's also it's like as a like
neuroscientist and this is actually how
we met isn't it weirdly like taboo now
to imply that male and female brains are
different in any way so i've gone this
route many times by saying
all those things and i think that
i'm allowed to say that but i kind of
put a lot of caveats i say look you guys
want to hear it and when you ask the
question let me tell you what you
actually ask and then i tell you what
actually is different so there are
differences between men and women's
brains to be clear but when people ask
the question most time they want to know
why they're buffering or not is not
great that's what they do right right
right right right
so that's but that is but that can still
be taught like a woman's brain this
can say that you just i think that the
the only issue is that you have to kind
of say to people in advance something
and afterwards so i'm going to cushion
that with telling you
what i'm going to say right now would be
offensive to some of you and you
wouldn't like it because it kind of
triggers this and that thing now i'm
going to tell you this thing and then
i'm going to in the end say also to
those of you who don't like hear it i
apologize and now you heard the effects
and you can do it
totally totally but like wouldn't you
rather know the truth
it's just sort of like i like if it's if
go debunk it go but like do what we do
and then go find the real true answer
like just the idea that we get to be
offended by science like is so confused
why would you want that why would you
want to not just know the truth i agree
and it also it's like it's not only
nature it's also nurture it's like women
you can't the same people they're like
men's and female brains are not
different biologically in any way or the
same people that are like the patriarchy
and social construction and we get wired
to survey so it's like nature and
nurture you can't have it both ways so
if you're saying that magazines and and
the expectations for women and toxic
masculinity
makes men and women different you then
can't say their brains aren't different
well because it's nice
if you don't want to touch it anymore
then you don't study it and then you
kind of perpetuate something that is
maybe wrong forever you might as well
say this is the truth we don't like it
let's fix it yeah yeah
um that's so wild to me okay so are
there like books and shit that are being
uh
like taken away
um i so i think that
we didn't get to burning books yet in
academia but definitely a lot of
academics like my colleagues who would
rehearse sentences that are about to say
just to avoid kind of hitting some wrong
chord and i think that it's
i mean you know just spend a little bit
i just wrote a book with a guy who talks
about basically this idea of like what's
the right thing to do and he says that
there will be a time where they're gonna
find pictures of you eating burgers and
you're going to be canceled for that
right it's going to be like 50 years
from now we're not going to have any
more 100 percent look at this picture we
found this woman eating a burger in
public like having your phone in the car
or like tweeting at work you were
talking about pole dancers yes
uh i still remember the guy's name but
he basically studied paul dancer's tips
he kind of looked at their tips and
looked at the time of the month when
they got different he showed that they
get a lot more money on the right days
so somehow even though they of course
don't broadcast that i'm fertile right
now the customers kind of feel that she
dances a little nicer or she's a little
bit more reddish in her cheeks something
and they give her more money so they
actually can when she's on her period
yeah when she's obviously i think when
she's ovulating oh yes
so the customer is going to say this one
ten dollars this one only eight
she was in a bitchy mood she's like give
me that fuck did they show her behavior
towards them so they said that somehow
between these smells here myths and the
behavior it kind of all works like we we
basically right now the fact that we're
doing it like if we were to do this
interview on the zoom we would talk
about different things of course us
being in the room makes us
feel different experience things
different we're on the same wavelengths
on some things and we talk about
different things
you want another one i have another one
yes
this is like my kink this is i'm just
obsessed with this shit so this one i
don't remember exactly i'm obsessed with
the invisible forces that drive us that
we just are not aware of i'll give you a
lot if you want yeah we're just zombies
of no you must just walk through the
world like everyone is such an idiot
they have no idea that they're just
being like puppets of their
like neurochemical cocktail i have a
good ending for us
a good ending for us
let's end i have a good ending that
speaks for that okay i will make sure
it's not a good ending i end these
horribly can try to ruin it so good this
will be our first good ending
i shouldn't forget okay
um so
the tears of women
it changed the testosterone of men
that's the kind of classical didn't
women evolve to cry because men were so
bad at reading faces and knowing when we
were in distress i don't know that
but generally there was a question so
here's the question the question was
like why do humans kind of cry with
water why do we when we get said water
comes out of our eyes there's a reason
to have tears in animals it cleans the
eyes it cancels the planet why do humans
do it when they feel sad and there are
many theories but one of them led to a
study that basically took the tears of
women put them in a bottle and started
to kind of break the chemicals and then
spray them in rooms with subjects to see
what happens to them and bottom line was
that you could see that it's about 11
feet radius that's when if you start
crying right now it will affect emily it
will affect me we will show a
drop in our testosterone which
effectively means that i'm going to be
much nicer but even if you don't know me
or care about me
but if what if there's just a little um
cup of tears here and we don't know
whose it is pull it anytime you want
like if you if you're kind of sitting
there and you want someone to be a
little bit less aggressive you just pull
your tears that is so
funny okay i would love to talk about
this because also what's nice is that
the study was done on female tears in
male subjects but it's unclear that it's
not also the same for men's deer and
women's testosterone no when men cry my
vagina gets very dried up
that's the si i don't know if that's a
sign
when men cry women just break up with
them
well i mean that is also very fucked up
that is like the fact that that is
repellent so fortunately they couldn't
find men to cry in the lab so they
didn't have this really they said
posters are saying like we want subjects
to come and try in the lab so we can do
it no man showed up so they just started
doing it that is so fucking funny but
those were just on the weirdos that
signed up to do a study for 50 bucks
it's a study there's a study on those
people it's called i think it's
something like the weirdest people on
earth i think the weirdest is actually
you i think by template so i think that
the weird is short for white
educated
industrious
rich
democratic
those are the people that basically
figure out most science is based on
those people yeah when they kind of put
a poster you get college kids they're
probably white educated industrial rich
democrat you study them and everything
we know about the brain or anything
comes from this tiny group of people
that aren't really the world but we
think that they're the world fascinating
so i think you and i fall in this
category kind of like white educated
yeah i mean it's it's interesting
because um i've managed to dismantle any
education i had by being a comedian for
20 years but um i uh it is wild to me
because yeah it's like i see all these
studies on like anxiety and depression
and i'm like
if you're sitting around like and get to
go to a study like you don't have
anxiety
like how can you be so depressed like
talk to the person that's like waiting
for the subway who can't afford to get
you know i mean it's like the people we
need to be studying would never have
time to sign up for these studies so the
fix that they have is that usually they
have kind of they take this entire pool
they break them into half and they do
some manipulation to half and not to the
same kind of group but so they can say
well it worked on this after the
manipulation works but
it's still a problem we're gonna reverse
anything you want but i'm curious
because
i think i got a
we did this a
kind of snooping in the neighborhood now
i feel like i can get access to you in a
very rare way like you're actually very
transparent so we're going to
use that for a second okay yeah and then
i'll let you if you off the hook if you
want if because i know people are
watching and like you might say this is
a person i don't want to talk about but
as long as you're letting me i'm going
to ask more questions okay
i'm very shy
really so no
very private person
i'm joking but there are certain it is
weird what makes me embarrassed it is
weird the things that are
name two things that make you
embarrassed um
uh
um
okay
sorry i'm stuttering because i just
thought to ask
is what embarrasses us
nature or nurture
and how much can you tell about
someone's past trauma based on what
embarrasses them um what embarrasses me
what's that what's that i'm gonna write
things i won't forget but i i'm with you
but um it i'm get embarrassed i get
really embarrassed when i'm late
uh you i i just i have shame about it
and i've spent so much time being like
when people are late that's their way of
saying my time's more valuable than
yours even though now if someone's 10
minutes late i'm like thrilled because
it gives me 10 minutes like ketchup on
text or like it's like free time that
you didn't have before so i kept you
know but when i get embarrassed because
i have a deep feeling that people think
i'm lying about why i'm late so if i'm
there's like traffic i'll extend a
picture of the traffic
because i like i'm i think people think
i'm lying which and then i get
embarrassed another one embarrassed by
being late another one embarrassed by
being late i'm embarrassed by um uh
when i
i think
oh my god there's so many
i mean they say comedians become
comedians to control how we're
embarrassed you know so it's like a lot
i've been able to get ahead of a lot of
things i'm embarrassed when i like
pronounce a word wrong that i've only
read
you know what i mean that that has
definitely uh the first time i said
chameleon i said shyamalan it was in
front of a lot of people
it's like when someone corrects me when
someone uh i introduce myself and
they're like we've met
you're trying to embarrass me and you it
worked
because then i get embarrassed in my
reaction because i i usually will go
pretty har cold bitch now like i'll be
like i'm sorry i don't remember you you
didn't have to do that and then i'm
embarrassed that i lost my grace i was
in a room with a woman who my age told a
story and kind of had the interaction
with people and live while she does a
story she realizes unicorns don't exist
she always started to exist and kind of
when she kind of she says something and
they're going everyone's kind of
laughing and she says and then i said
and then at some point i think because
of the responsibility she started to
kind of realize and you could says
i thought unicorns exist
and based basically responsibilities
they don't exist so it was like an adult
woman i guess no walls will fuck with
you though
i'm just saying there's sea unicorns
what embarrasses you
i feel like you don't put yourself in a
situation to ever do anything silly
i think big mistakes when i say
something like
as a and then someone says actually it
was
not at all true and i realized that it
was not a mistake i felt uncomfortable
here's in i get embarrassed sometimes
when sometimes when peop when i what is
this
i will ask for directions to a stranger
as soon as they start answering i just
disassociate and i just start looking at
like their pores and like zits and
eyebrows and and then they're like um so
is is that going to work
and then i have to admit that i didn't
hear anything they just said it's a
common these days people who
meet people in parties they kind of say
hi nice to meet you i'm with me shake
their hand two seconds later i have no
idea what the person is because we don't
even like makeup that's new like our
attention spans are just getting shorter
and shorter
i think that's i think we don't really
yeah we don't we don't make an effort i
think we can remember a word for 20
seconds it's just that someone says i'm
anthony you shake their hand you walk
away someone says what's this guy's name
i don't know i didn't hear it we're more
likely to remember something if it's
under traumatic circumstances right
emotions or like a negative emotion and
everyone knows what they were in 911 no
one knows where they were in 9 10.
there's also
you
all your work around memory i remember
when we were talking about this and it's
another thing that's kind of incendiary
to talk about the idea that like
our memories are
flawed and we all remember
all and also how do we know that we
let's look at them i know that
how did we know that what happened so
first of all okay so i'm sorry i didn't
i'm not done with questioning you but i
feel like it's your podcast
some memories uh
we've had a wrong model for memory
decades and then about 10 years ago we
kind of fixed it so the model we had and
the model that most people if you ask
them about whatever we tell you is how
it works is a model by which we are
talking right now you create a memory in
your mind you store it in your brain
that's it it sits there that's the model
we had and maybe you forgot at some
point but it's the model where memories
are there and they sit in your brain and
they're done what we learned in the last
10 years is that memories are more like
a telephone game meaning you put them
when you experience them in the vault
that's the same beginning but then if
someone asks you to tell them a story
about their memory so let's say we're
talking right now and someone asked you
tomorrow hey with me what did you do
yesterday and you say oh i was with this
guy and you load the memo and start
telling them about our interaction while
you talk about that your memory moves
from one place to another in the brain
and it's in a vulnerable state so
whatever the person you talk to is
saying right now when you're telling
them the story leaks into the memory so
if they tell if they laugh with
something that you didn't think it was
funny in its story it now becomes a
funny part if they interrupt you it
would become part of the they said this
part is not interesting enough so they
interrupted me like somehow whatever
they do to you whatever the temperature
in the room whatever your experience
when you talk about the memory is it's
gonna look into the memory the feedback
that they're giving you is going to
change the way that you
value certain parts of the story okay
the memory changes it's going to density
if i'm telling a story that's like
i was walking down the street and this
guy said uh give me your wallet by the
i've 40th time i've told her i'm like
and he runs up to me literally like
carrying a ninja star and he's like cunt
get like and i'm like this story has
exaggerated based on
people
like being concerned or liking the story
i've embellished the parts that they the
wolf is bigger in my story what is it
the wolf is bigger in my story that's
the yes yes
it's just sort of like that's not what
happened so it's not done okay so you
know i told the story and someone kind
of put dance into it by interrupting and
intervening and giving you ideas so now
we load the memory people put dent into
it and we're done talking about the
memory what happens right now is that
the brain takes it from the space it's
occupying when you talk about it and put
it back in the vault overwriting the
original so whatever was the original is
now being overwritten by the used memory
when you talk about it which means that
if in two weeks someone asks you about
today's conversation you're not loading
the original that you stored right now
you load the last thing that you spoke
about and put there so every time you
use the memory you load it change it put
it back
again load it change it put it back so
if someone asks you the memory that you
used a lot what they get is the last
version which could have been changed 10
times
and the original is far gone the cynical
joke among neuroscientists is that the
best memories are kept in the brains
with people with alzheimer's because
they never touch them they're kind of
raw they're sitting there no one touches
them so they're safe in a way we the
more we tell stories the more we change
them now this is not a bug
even though it means that the memory is
not the way it was in the beginning it's
kind of like a feature of the brain that
allows us to change so if your boyfriend
dumped you tomorrow and you felt
terrible you went to a therapist
therapist asks you to tell them
why you're feeling so sad then you load
the memo and you say he loved me so much
and then one day changing his mind and
okay so if she's a good therapist she's
going to say something like a but maybe
there are some reasons for that maybe
you can learn it and she is helping you
change the memory overwriting the
original you come back a week after she
says tell me again i break up you know
the memory now they're modified again
tell the story she gives you new
insights you save it again six times do
that you have a better version of the
same story you still remember it but
you're not really suffering from it if
it fails it's the same story again again
trauma again and again you load the same
memory without changing it so that's
like how our brain helps us change
things even bad ones rather than keep
reliving them without being able to go
away and is the biological basis for
that that the more engrossing your story
is the more protection you have or
something like there's got to be a
biological base like you would think
that we evolved to have perfect memories
to keep ourselves safe which i guess
when we're right we hold on to a memory
five times more strongly if there was
adrenaline if we were scared during it
right so also if there's um
like why does it benefit us as a species
to
every time we tell a story
exaggerate it is it because it means
like we're keeping attention more so we
don't have to exaggerate this but we
have to tell it multiple times and this
is our brain's way of allowing us to
change so the worst case would be that
you you know you go to a bad experience
now you have a memory and that's it this
is like how it is you can't change it
you keep every time you think about the
one time that you got injured it's it's
making you feel scared and terrible and
you elevate your heart rate this way you
can remember bad things without
relieving them that's the
because also there's a um i've always
like sort of uh
what uh been curious about how uh when
something's traumatic we remember it
very intensely but also sometimes uh
people cope by like
like blacking it out like my most a lot
of the most traumatic things that
happened to me is a child like i've
completely blacked out i can't remember
anything but then other really dramatic
things i remember like the smell of the
room and the feel of the carpet so i
think when does your brain decide which
one to delete and you also get because
the memories are not fixed and you can
kind of load unload them it also allows
you to change what you so if it's in
your brain
because it's this nice mechanism that
kind of allows you to load it put it
back allow it to put it back you can if
at some point in your life you feel
ready to encounter these things it's
there and your brain will let you pick
it up and use it and right now you're
not allowed you're not ready to do it so
the brain helps you kind of put it down
so in a way the brain is very very smart
in helping us use memories in the best
ways that service us kind of to have a
functional life it's like remembering
things that will help you stay safe but
not keep you paralyzed and sad all the
time a lot of people ask if you can
delete me movies like you know a breakup
to people say i want to erase the
boyfriend in a way the answer is first
of all we can but it's like very weird
how we do it but the answer is that most
memories include the bad ones are there
for a reason like we need them like
that's how you know to not go to the
next boyfriend that's the same sure why
would you want to delete all the lessons
or the muscle memory of like i know how
that ends yeah it's you know but also um
or maybe is there anything to do with it
disassociating sorry to go into like
bummer territory but like when you're
like
molested as a child sometimes so that's
just blocked out but if b during that
time that something traumatic was
happening if you disassociated are you
less likely to remember it so right now
we know that trauma generally is trauma
is it's like to be kind of the most
clear trauma is when you have this
memory and you keep loading it and
saving and loading and saving and it
doesn't change
it's typically a bad thing right like
you don't want to have that you want to
be able to change and it is
kind of characterized by the fact that
some bad experiences when our brain is
not ready for them are
becoming that like kind of the brain
basically marks this as memory that
doesn't let you change and you have to
work and how does your brain know you're
not ready for it like your blood
pressure rises or cortisol is emitted
like how does it know so a lot of so
it's even genetics so some people some
some people are just born with different
genetic
structure making that makes them more
likely to be caught by trauma so bad
experiences that happen to the two of us
might leave an imprint of trauma on you
and not only even though we're in the
same womb and we both experienced this
you know exploding tank and we're in the
same way but is that epigenetic
imprinting so there's some genetic
component like we can look at some
people and say this person is more
likely there's like a gene that kind of
marks that then there's also experiences
in life that basically says if you're a
person that
endured a lot of trauma you might
actually have a different kind of
baseline and now the next drama is gonna
you know holocaust survivors kind of
they've seen a lot when they see another
bad thing it kind of is painted compared
to a lot of bad experiences and they say
okay yeah it's bad thing i know it's bad
but this doesn't leave a mark because i
already had this many marks that now i
can kind of deal with that so i think
that your experience is how many traumas
you had
definitely shapes like what's the next
one's gonna
i'm obsessed with like inherited fears
and like just like the um
like
this is gonna be too like basic but like
the idea like if someone's really afraid
of heights is it safe to kind of be like
yeah someone in your ancestry fell off a
fucking cliff like there's
if you're like terrified of snakes like
yeah your answers just probably got
so i think i think the nice way i'll
face it for you the nice way to make you
feel happy about inherited memories
most times the things that we inherit in
terms of brain are
the mistakes of our forefathers are
imputed enough so we cannot make the
same mistakes the fact that we
i don't know we were born and we're
startled by loud no noises even though
we've never heard them before it's a
baby you kind of play on the baby is
scared it's because aren't babies afraid
of pictures of spiders even though they
don't know what they're saying the
famous famous study with the
monkeys and apes and snakes you take a
babies monkey just spawn showed a
picture of a snake it gets scared like
elevated it doesn't even know what it is
yeah that's what it is but it basically
knows impotent on his hardware of the
brain that
things that look like a stick that move
that fast that moving distraction that's
moving that kind of type of movement how
bad and that's how we respond to
startling sounds to darkness generally
to heights
a lot of things because
back in the savannah you know hundred
thousand years ago there are two monkeys
uh monkey let's let's take here's
the classical story there are two
monkeys
and one monkey looks at the tree there
and see the banana and he says i'm going
to go get the banana and then you see
the lion
200 feet away and he kind of says hmm i
don't know put an excel kind of pretty
stable pro banana con it says on the one
hand on one column is like my speed
versus the lion speed how tasty the
banana is versus how tasty am i to the
lion makes all the equations realizes at
the top of the equation that getting to
the banana too risky doesn't go walks
away the other another monkey does the
same calculation figures that should be
the banana goes tries to get a banana
it's eaten by the lion with the
descendant of the monkey that made the
right calculation
and its son made similar calculations
and it's summoned against
this is where i get tripped up couldn't
the monkey that was eaten by the lion
have procreated before he was eaten by
the lion yeah so so we will have some
we'll have some some bad monkey bit
bunkies with bad excel files out there
yeah presumably at some point those are
going to be eaten by by lions that's
kind of darwin's idea so yeah i think
that the the bad ones
predominantly decay because of franzen
the good ones survive and we're the
descendant of the good ones and at some
point the brain is amazing and saying
okay you know what all monkeys in the
lineage like five generations they all
spent a lot of time calculating with
excel lions speed and bananas taste and
my speed
it seems like it's something that's
important let's put it in the brain in a
place where he doesn't need to be
conscious anymore we're just gonna fill
it instead of thinking it so instead of
putting excel the monkey's gonna look at
the excel and the tree and it's just
feel fear
and then it said i don't know what the
excel behind this thing i'm just feeling
bad and i'm gonna walk away so the
emotions are those imprints of our
fathers now the monkey just feels afraid
and this afraid feeling is the summary
of a lot of calculations that his dad
and his grandfather and his great
grandfather did that now manifest
himself in i don't feel good about this
banana i'm going away is this called a
like gut like is that what we would call
like your gut instinct which is by the
way part of why in my um my experience
building robots uh and learning about
part of the reason everyone's like you
know that
everyone's like the robots are gonna
take over they're not gonna take over
it's gonna take so fucking long because
of that and it's going to take so long
for them to be able to be able to make a
judgment call until they're able to tell
the difference between a wolf and a
husky dog
they're not going to be able to do
anything we're not going to let them
feel so we can just instinctively tell
the difference between a husky like a
domesticated husky and a wild wolf i
think i think in my my way of saying
that like academically is we say that
a great ai
will give you the best chess move out
there while the house is burning yes
totally because the way that robots
right now are programmed is they make
they get like points basically for doing
the right thing and they're just trying
to get as many points as possible and
they're trying to be as efficient as
possible and efficiency is not always
the way to do something humans are
wildly inefficient but it's part of the
reason we're not just like
you know injuring each other as much
accidentally so
they said we need you to get on top of
the table the order was for the robot to
get on top of the table so go he's just
going to jump or he's going to he
smashed the table down
and then
stepped on top of it because the better
way to do it was to make the table
smaller so he was going to use less
energy if he just broke it i have a
colleague in england who basically talks
about ai coming to get us kind of and
he's
his
argument is that most people when talk
about it kind of imagine terminator like
they come with guns and they shoot us he
said they're going to kill us if they
ever kill us not by kind of coming with
nuclear weapons and shooting us by by
mundane thing we're going to give them a
task to calculate pi to the one trillion
decimal point and they're gonna
immediately eliminate humanity because
they're gonna say okay my task is to
calculate pi humans take a lot of energy
let's kill humans so i can do the task
better and that's like we're gonna be
the collateral of the task that they are
giving like you know say do this say
fine let's just kill humans first i can
do it better because they take energy
and boom now that's kind of how pies
like it's forever and it's like when
you're i'm fascinated by when you're
like driving and there's a car coming
towards you the way you're able to
ascertain whether you're gonna make it
or not that just comes from experience
of just being like okay i just know how
fast that car is going from over there
i'm gonna make it opposed to not like
they're just like not i mean they're
gonna obviously be able to calculate
that because that's a different machines
can do that but there's certain things
where it's like oh
that's a husky no bitch that's a wolf
that's going to eat we know the
difference like you feel it like just
our psychic
um little and we can fool them easily
and whether you get goosebumps or not
like until they can get goosebumps just
because they we can like catch feelings
we can catch
shit that they just won't be able to do
right there's a guy like danny hill is a
machine learning guy he says that he
wants to build a computer that's going
to be proud of him that's his kind of
hallmark for a success he wants a
computer that's going to be proud of him
like he's going to code it and the girl
is very proud of him i think he has kids
now so i probably got it already but
i thought i had a weird relationship
with my dad um
that is why that is i mean look but also
it's like you can anthropomorphize
anything like you can project that on
anything it's like when that to me the
bigger fear is how we anthropomorphize
things like you know the roomba which is
like the little
the vacuum thing um i had one in my old
house and one time it got stuck under
the
couch and it was like
trying to get out and i was like oh my
god honey like i like felt sad for it
there's actually a study on that mit
media live they had a study similar they
took a turtle robot that has it kind of
walks around in the room and it has one
mission which is that it gets ten
percent battery it finds the power port
goes plug this element that's basically
the roomba thing and they brought kids
to watch it and they see the kind of
robots moving around and at some point
it's in the very other end of the room
and it has the person it starts going
there and it's kind of slowing down kids
started crying parents run to help it
yeah that's okay
is it which is why isn't the argument
like right now about whether robots uh
should have human faces or not
exhibit a because we can't we can't we
can't help but like get emotionally
attached to them
i think even even kind of what type of
human face is like an entire thing
should it be like is it about like
having the shape of a face or is it
having the kind of feeling like you're
emotionally connected to it oh is this
gestures also something like some you
can make a faceless robot but it does
the gestures of like this when you play
music right right right enough for like
people to feel that okay it's getting me
it's in the rhythm it's interesting what
makes
a human uh anthropomorphized something
or like what needs to happen like
whether it needs to be cute whether it
needs to seem vulnerable you know i
think those are when we emotionally
connect but
a lot of times when people see her it's
like like men get really weirded out
creeped out and isn't the basis of that
pathogen avoidance where when men see
something that
ostensibly looks human but doesn't like
move like a human or exactly look like a
human that uncanny valley it's a way to
make them recoil so they don't fuck it
because it could two thousand years ago
have been something that was sick or
dead and not not produced also not
reproduced like you can't do anything
with it it can't reproduce yeah well
that's what you guys look for now that's
the opposite they can't recoil when you
say you're not on birth control hi hi hi
hi we're going to take a little break
we're easing into a break
easing into a break to talk to you guys
about
neutral fall
neutral fall it's simple
simple addition to your daily routine
four pills a day and you will begin to
have thicker stronger faster growing
hair in three to six months i don't want
to have to say this but i need this
desperately i don't know what's
happening where i mean i did bleach my
hair for two years that probably didn't
help
but it's getting thinner in a way you
know like when i take a shower or brush
my hair
the um if full
ferret
comes out yeah you're shedding the
amount of hair that i'm it is terrifying
to me so neutral fall is going to handle
that anxiety for me i hope my pubes
don't grow back that's what i was
wanting to see how potent it is oh okay
visit neutraful.com and take their hair
wellness quiz for personalized product
recommendations that are unique to your
hair's needs and then you can maybe make
a note about not wanting to lose your
throw your pubes back okay yeah yeah you
can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com and entering the promo
code gfy to save 15 off your first
month's subscription that is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time how
could you ever been asking me for my uh
nutrafull tagline or my tagline for
every
i realized that we forgot that
and i want do you have one right now for
neutral yeah of course
i always have a great tagline right let
me hear it
don't be a fool
get neutral wow
plus free shipping on every order get 15
off at nutrifoal.com spelled n u t r a f
o l dot com promo code g f y i have a
new one i i i realize you guys didn't
like that one ready right it was just
okay okay i have a better one neutral
no one wants to fuck a bald guy
[Laughter]
is that better that was that's great
chefs which also is not true by the way
there is science they can make it work
there is science that says that is that
it's even hotter when a guy right
because they have more testosterone
doesn't have hair yeah yeah but yeah
look no one wants to fuck a bald girl
that is just true and i'm sorry about
that it is true unless you're jada in
which case
it seems like
at least one person we should not have
brought that up right before we're
talking about the shows i know i know
how about this here's the fine tag one
okay neutral
jada doesn't use it
yeah
we gotta end
[Laughter]
um i am touring uh more and more and
more it never ends and i am uh touring
away my ability to have biological
children to make you guys laugh june
24th i'll be in calgary prince island's
park alberta canada you wanted me to
come i'm coming let's do this june 27
june 26th i'll be in toronto ontario at
the danforth music hall and there's a
couple rescheduled shows because
i blame united but on september 8th i'm
coming to cincinnati ohio all of your
tickets are going to work for the taft
theater show that was rescheduled
september 9th philadelphia pennsylvania
miriam theatre september 10th richmond
virginia the national september 24th
charlottesville virginia this is all on
my website why do i have to read this i
love you guys see you soon
okay i have i've i have literally three
pages of questions for you i know i'm
jumping around
um placebo effect i'm obsessed with it i
the the question i had the other day
actually for a vet was with a dog i was
like will placebo effect work for a dog
if i think it's working for the dog like
do they catch it yeah guess the answer
they do
that's so funny so so placebo generally
so we know a lot more as of the last
three years possible than what we knew
before
first of all we know of course they work
right like we know that but are doctors
allowed to use the placebo effect
without telling you isn't that illegal
so so now so the doctors have brought
them there's some doctors who kind of do
that and there's nothing to tell you
this is placebo and it still works
because by the way i was like by the way
it is the greatest uh
way to fix any problem
but it's at least used by doctors i feel
like so so i think that because we know
socialism right now there are doctors
who would be experts on the placebo
users like for instance
we know the placebo works but it works
better if the pain if the pill is blue
than if it's red so they would say this
placebo we'll give you the blue one oh
straight that's that's much better
bigger pills are better than smaller
peels this is still placebo so you know
that you're getting nothing sugar but
still like works a little bit better if
it's blue then if it's red if it's
bigger if it's small if it's a less
tasty than more tasty like things like
that work on our brain the same way
because at the end what is placebo it
makes our brain actually do real things
so so in the end placebo is just kind of
screwing with our brain making us think
that something is going to do something
and then we activate in the brain the
parts that will do something they
activate the immune system they will
speed up some secretion of proteins so
in the end real things happen so placebo
works because can you self-medicate
placebo
so
if you think about like the experience
of the doctor there are like multiple
components of this experience and some
of them are placebo it comes from you
some comes from the doctor so for
instance we know that if doctor wears a
white coat the treatment is going to
work better than if they don't even if
kind of independent of what's so wild
if they use a syringe it's going to work
better than if they just say something
else if they uh i forget there's like a
list of things that like the environment
if it's if it's in a place that you have
to work how to get to it's going to work
differently and one of them some of
those things so those are all external
they're also going to work better if you
yourself the doctor's wearing glasses
like shit like that jewish last name
okay
like totally yeah
okay uh all of those things come from at
you from the outside and then from the
inside there's also kind of you came to
the doctor and you believe it's going to
work
you came thinking hearing from a friend
that they went to this doctor and worked
so all of those things actually they
kind of prepare the brain for the
elevator brain into a state where
whatever's gonna happen in the womb is
gonna work even better
placebo still just because you're in
this mindset and i think in that sense
the brain is
not just like sitting there passively
and getting input and doing things it's
getting itself ready and responding to
even that so if you're playing a better
game in a home game compared to an
outside game in basketball even though
it's the same hands and it's the same
basket but somehow the brain is kind of
in a different state and you end up
playing better basketball when you're in
but is that like is that also because
like you're in a familiar place you're
not like distracted by unfamiliar things
maybe and maybe like you know you know
your friends are there and they're
looking at you so you feel like you're
so in the end and you have history of
succeeding here so it's like i
i believe in myself some of those are
cues basically from the environment cues
that affect our brain in the end the mix
of like what's inside what's outside and
how we think about it ends up actually
having an effect so we actually get
better when we're
going through those things knowing that
it's placebo like in the end it's still
possible it's just that our brain is
responding to those things and we get
better
but is there it do doctors have to tell
you if they're giving you a placebo
i don't know a product i bet i bet so i
think that placebo is mostly done not
really as a treatment but it's like as a
test so you wanna you wanna test a drug
you give some people some drug i wanna
start like my own like pfizer that's
just placebos
okay
put a chip inside like to make it put a
piece
want to have a like a big pharma company
but know nothing about
chemistry like you get a booster for
this procedure yeah like it's all
placebo but like it's i'll give you this
it comes in the syringe it's like
whatever so you see has to check the
placebo to make sure it works like why
not i think i think so and if if you're
kind of going to a world where you want
to
help people
and
that that should be a solution like
really that's that's something that's
great but there's some things that are
there some
parts of the body that are or uh that
are more resistant to placebo effect
because
it's more necessary
for example like there's some things you
can't talk yourself into happening or
there's some things that aren't
psychology pain i think for sure is
psychological like the more you talk
about them or you think about being sick
like i'm getting sick
but like
what's resistant to placebo so i think i
would say placebo would not work if it's
not a brain related thing again like
this is like a mind over matter thing
like i'm going to puke
so so it will i think i i bet it will
work so everything that your brain is
involved with placebo would help so so
i don't think it's the recommended
answer to kind of things that have a
solution like if you have a drug that
works and you get a placebo you're
probably going to get a drug that works
better but in that sense
knowing that you're in their kind of
mindset that is more conducive to work
placebo birth control
probably doesn't work
it's not a great sell to your boyfriend
no it's a placebo it works just as well
so i think anything that does involve
brain will work like like breath control
you don't like it doesn't matter
it's mechanical yeah yeah it's like
because i'm like can you do a placebo
effect with birth control on someone and
then are they going to smell people
differently
so don't try that just for me
do not try placebo
yeah that's just it is so fascinating to
me but like when you
really process the placebo thing
it's a mind fuck because then it makes
me just go like we are all
um
like nothing's real it makes me go into
like an existential crisis like where
our minds are so powerful
but also it just makes me like nothing
i've ever done is real and i'm
so i see the difference everything's
power of suggestion i think it's
beautiful like the the fact that our
mind creates manufactures reality and
nothing is real
is
it's a broad statement it's kind of like
a beautiful thing it means that the
existence like
is in our mind we can
change it we can work it out if
something doesn't work for us we can
actually create a different reality we
don't we're not bound to the altitude i
think i like it but don't you get
annoyed that like
there's no i just want something to be
true
like i just want to have a headache like
someone like i don't want this to be me
making a like everything is my choice
now like everything like it just makes
me a little bit
uh uh
exhausted at the idea of like well
everything's what i make of it and so
it's like you're in a relationship and
you're like well maybe if i just
you know if i just like this person more
i'm gonna like them more and it's all in
my head when i do that it's all in my
head thing then i get really overwhelmed
i agree so you can take it if you
basically say nothing is that it kind of
dismissed reality and you left with
nothing that the silicon valley is full
of people who do that in the matrix like
it's all meaningless and so on this this
is also not really helpful because in
the end you have to everyone have to
play the same game for this to work like
if you do it but no one else does
totally totally
is neuralink gonna happen in our
lifetime
there
yes so let's explain to the audience
what it is so neural link it's elon
musk's like the it's um a screen into
your brain right your mind reading
software basically so he's a yeah so
he's his idea basically if you take it
all the way to the end yes that kind of
steps on the way is to put an implant
and chip inside a human brain and the
chip is interacting with your brain
reading brain signals but also talking
to outside world in hiso just is it
still true that men think about sex
every seven seconds or something do you
guys really want to broadcast do we
really want to broadcast our thoughts to
everyone so you can you can you will
have to kind of switch to choose you can
say well don't broadcast this one this
is i don't want anyone to know but you
still can uh
put us what you want the whole point of
thoughts is that they're too awful to
say
you know what i'm saying i'd rather
choose what i you know there's nothing
you have the control
you will give you the control then
you're just spending all this time
editing out all your thoughts so you had
it in your mind already i didn't have it
in my mind
what he says is like okay she has it in
her mind i'm gonna read it from her mind
send it to the cloud and then broadcast
it from
the cloud into moron's brain and now he
sees what she says here's the thing that
really blows my mind this is kind of
like a stoner thought but like when
you're spending a lot of time with
someone or you've known someone forever
like you never know what they're
thinking like that to me is the
one of the only interesting parts about
living is you're trying to figure out
people's motives and you're trying to
figure like that's what we do that's
what good drama is that's what good
comedy is is like that people
we never know what's really going on
what their inner life is like like
people that you are really close to have
a whole inner life
without you and it's blows my mind and i
i would i would take it one step further
even you have in your life that you
don't know of even in your mind like you
think okay i i ask a question you'll
give me an answer chances are that this
is not the true answer for you
oh no
like i don't wanna the neural link i
that i'm gonna know what i'm thinking
like i don't even like that now i'm in a
real nightmare so that i think is the
reason don't talk about so everyone can
say okay well i'm gonna be exposed
everyone's gonna know but what if like
we learn that thoughts that we had and
were able to suppress are gonna come up
again and again and we're starting to
kind of confront things that we don't
like about ourselves i think to me
that's equally
troubling of this world so what are they
doing so what they're doing is they're
basically taking a little chip putting
it right now in the brains of pigs and
this chip has twins tiny kind of little
electrodes that are the size of a neuron
a brain cell so it's like a microphone
sitting next to our brain cell and just
reading what's happening there and they
put it let's say next to the pig's
motor cortex so the pig
raises his right foot there are cells in
the brain that fire just before and a
second are the food raises and they say
okay this cell controls the food going
up and then they find another cell that
when the cell fires the second order the
left would rise up so you said this one
controls the left so they basically map
first in the brain of a pig
neurons and what they do
it gets hungry it's about to make a
sound it's about to i don't know move
left move right and so on so they kind
of map those and now they can just
forget about the pig look at this chip
and they say i see that this neuron this
cell is firing i don't even have to look
at the peak right now the peak is moving
left i can look at this one it's firing
the pig is raising his hand so they can
interpret the pig's thoughts
think about that in the context of
humans and you can say okay i'm putting
it in the brain of whitney and i map
first that this is the cell in her brain
that codes her mom this one codes her
dead this one codes her best friend this
one called her boyfriend so now i'm not
being looking whitney i'm just waiting
for her to
sit there and this one fires and i say
oh she's taking out her mom right now
boom i read your thoughts and now i can
broadcast it out there and use it for
something
for example
you sit there and you're asking yourself
when was the french revolution
i can see that you're asking this
instead of just saying okay i'm going to
leave her with the question pondering in
her mind i'm going to actually ping
wikipedia look at the
entry see the answer and then see it's
1799 i'm going to zap neurons in her
brain so she just thinks 299 and she
will just know the answer without me
knowing that it went outside um so
okay yes so i'm as someone that is very
like pro technology and i'm the first
person to say every problem we have
today we've always had some iteration
like everyone's like canceled culture
it's like we went through this with the
simpsons we went through this with
eminem we went through that like this
has always happened and we're always
stunned it's like um you know and
i was like we're gonna talk about like
social media and how you know or phones
people like bones is the worst thing
ever it's like they thought that about
trains but you don't say like
just because a train crashed once we're
gonna just trains are awful i'm saying
like people used to be afraid of
elevators they thought they were gonna
get elected when they got down like
technology is always people always only
look at the bad in the beginning i'm
kind of fascinated by that like we don't
just stop using airplanes because some
of them crash you know what i mean or
you get radiation like you just have
there's two things can be true at once
with this neural link thing i'm i'm more
obsessed with the things that we lose
skill-wise when another technology comes
in like whatever atrophies like let's
say that social media has made uh kids i
don't know if this is true or not uh
worse that having conversations let's
say or worse at reading body language or
something like what
evolutionary advantages are we going to
lose once we have neural links so we're
definitely going to lose so let's let's
start with kind of the news like what's
going to atrophy
so already
just because of kind of the nature of
the technology right now we're getting
worse in memory
yeah you probably don't remember emily's
phone number
let's guest let's see let's broadcast
everyone 9-1-1
well emily yes i never did know her
phone number but i love that you said
that because when i got my ear bitten
off by a dog and i had to go to the
emergency room i i didn't have my phone
and they were like we need an emergency
contact i did not know one person's
phone number i had to call my i called
caa i
oh my god that's so funny
i i went to instagram and i dm'd a guy
that i had met on raya and um
the nurses like dm'd him and he like
went to get my phone it was a nightmare
so many things i wanna take on this
story but that's one thing that other
phrases
so memory so also navigation so
navigation basically the hippocampus in
the brain the center kind of the middle
temporal lobe is a part of the brain
that's good for navigation when you
drive a car that's the path basically
tells you go left or right and so on and
that but that's not because we're using
like ways and maps and stuff like that
we just are less yeah we basically so
not only do we not kind of we outsource
all of that we also don't really spend a
lot of time looking at cues that will
help us so there's there's that's a nice
story there's this tribe in a it's an
emergency drive in australia called the
cook tire
and they don't have any of the
technology and not only that but they
use
cues to navigate the world much
different than us is in they always know
where they are and so on so if i take
you right and say whitney close your
eyes turn 30 times open your eyes where
is your right hand where's your left
hand you would know because you just
align it yourself and you know when if i
ask you where is north you might not
know where it is if you're not in this
room these guys are the opposite because
they so are used to using cues
if you kind of make them close their
eyes and turn around 10 times and you
open their eyes they just say this is no
they have no problem knowing where north
is and it's because the entire world is
kind of centered around that for example
they would say something like whitney
you have an ant crawling on your north
west arm so the entire kind of
calibration for them is geography and in
that sense they they wouldn't say right
and left they would say that's my
currently western um that's my eastern
army if i turn around now it's my
northern army so they kind of use that
because they're hippocampus looks
totally different like you can actually
see that you're cooked tired by looking
at the brain because they had to
build different connections that will
allow them to constantly keep a map of
the world because that's how they think
so cook tire on one end kids with phones
the opposite right now very little
navigation losing it becoming worth it
but also like aren't there some things
that like you know for example um
the
wasn't there a study that kids that
played video games are actually have bet
uh faster responses in real life there's
a lot of good things also so i think
that we tend to kind of speak at the bad
sides of social media and phones and so
on because we don't like corn has made
guys better fucking let's just say it
poetry okay
um
that i don't i don't i don't know i i
can always find like levity and all this
stuff like i don't
you know i think to me
happiness whatever whatever is just to
be able to not
get upset about upsetting shit and just
like find the comedy in it you know it's
like the stuff of like this is ruining
us it's like or not
you know what i'm saying the cortisol
you're admitting worrying about it right
now is actually worse for you probably
than the thing yeah you know you're just
like this self-righteous ending nation
and need to worry about everything that
has been like progress it's just like
the spider that's not as bad as bad as
it thoughts themselves the spiral like
starting to kind of ruminate and bad
things and spiraling into it is
sometimes as bad as the kind of trigger
right now kind of elevating it in your
brain you want to get out of it like
you're you're basically doing this thing
like you pull memories change them load
them pull them gently but like just keep
fighting bad things into them by that
good ones like i've only i've had not
really had a psychiatrist much but i
have one that i talked to like once a
month now um and uh that counts as
having a psychiatrist
[Laughter]
well a therapy's like an everyday thing
no that is so funny i don't know for
some reason i thought you'd do it once a
week or i don't know for like 28 years
or something but yeah so because i went
on prozac 10 milligrams of prozac for
just like repetitive thoughts and um
total miracle whether placebo or not
it's such a baby dose but he said he was
like he's like happiness and success um
as the way he defines it is just uh the
qualities the quality of your problems
increase
and ever since he kind of like said that
to me that everything that's a problem
i'm just like as long as this is a
better quality problem that i had two
years ago i'm happy working
yeah it's working for me it's just like
a little mind fuck that was like oh if
my social media making me
be toxic is like if that's my biggest
problem today life's pretty good
happiness is one of the biggest things
in neuroscience in research right now
because a lot of academics realize that
they can actually answer questions of
how to make people happy and we're going
there and i think that's a wonderful
thing a lot of people find answers to
what happiness is and how to make it and
how to what doesn't make you happy
really know the answers but i also i
have trouble with that because um
because as someone that has like a very
um i'm very involved
in the addiction the world of addiction
and addiction recovery and one of the
you know adages in addiction recovery is
saying that alcoholics alcoholics being
defined by anyone with alcoholic
behavior you don't have to have like
whiskey in a plastic bag you know um
it's just your uh uh
out for alcoholism to be present alcohol
doesn't have to be present it could be
gambling it can be deading uh defining
alcohol is any addictive behavior right
um doing uh doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result with diminishing marginal returns
and um
uh and then it stops being fun but to me
alcoholics like one of the main things
we say is alcoholics are the only people
that think they should be having fun all
the time like don't conflate boredom and
serenity don't like
i need to be happy all the time and like
if in order for happiness to happen or
whatever you have to have contrast so
bad things have to happen in your life
too so it's also this like need for
everyone to be happy all the time i see
is so bratty
because it's just like go then go do an
esteemable action like go be of service
like go
like it's one of the things okay let's
play again someone that's worried about
like being happier like you're
your life is already so good that you
know like jim's saying it's such a
luxury to even think that way yeah a
person who's like right now busy serving
their life doesn't go figure out what
makes you happy or like go be
interesting i don't like i just it's
shocking to me it's actually funny
enough started by economists so so it's
not like you you're hitting the right
thing that the people who wanted study
happiness first were economists because
they said oh if we figure out what makes
people happy we're going to make them
buy whatever it is more and we're going
to basically control the economy so it's
started by the wrong people yeah by
people who kind of basically wanted to
manipulate hypnosis but it's also tricky
because it's also like it's it you know
it's about like your life choices too
because to me it's like i just i
struggle with being happy yeah i see the
people you surround yourself with get
fucking rid of them do i mean they want
someone else to make them happy it's
your job to make yourself happy and i
just don't understand how scientists are
going to come in and be like here's the
magic happy thing it's like no bitch you
need to change your life
you already said two things that
actually are true like what what what
control your happiness is we are
surrounded by that's uh kind of so we're
not going to tell you who to bring but
we tell you that you should take care of
that and or care about that because who
you're around is going to affect your
happiness so that's kind of learning one
mm-hmm what else did you say i think you
said something like about go help others
i think that's a another one of the big
things in happiness being of service
yeah yeah and then also attuning to
equals right like the amount of eye
contact we get a day the thing that i
like in a slideshow is that okay they
took the word like money doesn't buy
happiness that's kind of the classical
theorem and they made it into if money
doesn't buy happiness you're spending it
the wrong way but they just yes i love
that and it's also i think that it's
just to me it's just this this
brattiness entitlement of like you know
when people like i'm miserable it's like
then stop following people that make you
feel bad about yourself on social media
like you have to do
because it's also to me the happiness i
get is from pride of my own choices like
making good choices so to me it's like i
i just don't look too in because of this
program like i don't look to external
things for internal needs like it's we
say happiness is inside job like you
can't go to external things to meet
internal needs so for you to be happy
like that's just it's on you this whole
thing that like i need to read a book
about how to be happy and this to be
happy it's just like it's just so
wild to me
yes say it again number one quality of
happiness emily what it is
number one quality of all the things you
can do that will make you the happiest
drugs
number one thing to make you happy
health
no it's it's a big one but not sleep
number one oh
i should be very yeah
but it's also yeah but if you sleep all
the time it's depression yes
um so so even if if you're not
i don't think you are i'm sorry you're
not depressed emily so if i say you were
letting you score like on the depression
score from like one to ten uh seven on
depression it means that you could have
been and you sleep well you could have
been
lower if you didn't sleep well so
whatever it is your state sleep is
making so i'm so depressed
that only my all my sleeping is bringing
me to a
higher depression can i ask you a
question do you i think it's more that
when you're i think to me
and this isn't about being your body to
me exercising stretching like
accomplishing something achieving
something is how i
derive the serotonin and worse so to me
it's like if i'm sleeping too much it
just means i'm doing less of something
productive and then i don't feel pride
i'm like i wasted the day away i just
fucking slept i got nothing done you
know it's like so it's not like
it's more the lack of having done other
things that are productive or a positive
investment in my future self you know
like if i'm doing sleeping instead of
exercise right instead of a truth you
know what i mean so i sleep a lot i
sleep like do you dream numbers yeah i
dream do you dream a lot so you're
getting fears worked out like nightmares
sleep
like i'll go to bed on
friday
night and wake up sunday morning like
i'll sleep
over 24. sleeping beauty
van winkle
yeah that is
wild to me yeah i love it because i mean
there's no sound like like
i'll wake up to go to the bathroom
sometimes but like i will wake up and
like not know
you'll sleep is that is that and that is
something that i mean it's all six hours
you also were um she was raised she was
loved uh if you i think i don't know if
you can do that if you were raised in
like an alcoholic home or like every
sound wait like for me i have like such
bad misophonia like every sound wakes me
up like everything is
like i'm always it takes are you hard to
wake up
no hmm
but i've always been like that even my
mom said when i was a baby like she
couldn't wake me up like
all i wanted to do was sleep did you
have any hours sorry how many hours do
you collect
sleep
whitney's not a good two
truly like i don't like i i have really
i have a lot of trouble sleeping but i
just i don't need as much sleep as
everyone else
i don't think
i do and we don't know so i think that i
think to so what we're learning about
sleep is so the big answer
because people are listening is that
sleep is good for you should sleep more
that's the kind of thing but we're
learning more and more about sleep is
that you actually can have different
kind of chronotypes and some people can
benefit from sleep of two hours just as
much as they can benefit from three
hours the right time and something like
that is what's making me not sleep is
this stress of if i don't fall asleep
i'm not gonna get eight hours and i'm
not a high performer and i'm falling
behind and fucking back i'm glad well so
we have to sleep eight hours like this
whole press this whole shaming everybody
of like you have to meet an ice bath
every day you have to be in a sauna
every you have to sleep eight hours like
that's causing me so much more stress
than this is supposed to be relieving so
to me
i'm like i'm like i feel fine can you
stop sleep shaming me like i don't like
the
the sleep shame shit i don't like the
you're right so sleep doctor will tell
you the same like if you're sitting in
bed and you don't feel like sticking
starting get anxiety
pressure yeah you're right that's not a
good idea to like the sleep pressure is
added
negative thing that will actually ruin
your sleep my
therapist had told me a while ago there
was a theory and tell me if i'm getting
this wrong like the theory of like night
watchers like in tribes there were
certain people that were had to be up
all night and they bred with each other
so there's just certain people that
at night is sort of when they're more
awake and alert they even the reason we
have different kind of sleep cycles is
part of that because if you know if the
truck goes to sleep between 6 p.m and 6
a.m because that's when it's dark
and not everyone is like emily can sleep
12 hours
it's useful to have some people who fall
asleep at six and wake up at midnight
and some people that actually aren't
able to first sleep at six and they only
wake up at midnight so it kind of like
allowed us to spread or diversify sleep
types so we'll always have someone to
sleep and in deep sleep and always have
someone alert and awake so like the
night watchers basically were able to
figure out who is the person that sleeps
well at six to midnight and he is taking
the
midnight to six a.m shift and the other
guy is the update so it's kind of like
we optimize over years for sleep
diversity so you and other people aren't
sleeping at the same time and this now
is hard for us because we are leaving
the world right now that kind of created
structure that everyone should sleep at
like midnight to seven a.m and we were
thinking about that but then does the
placebo effect apply to sleep i'm like
no i slept eight hours last night i feel
great he does people so the the i
i just lie to myself and i'm like i
think the challenge of sleep right now
is partially the world we created we go
to the world that uh you know like
school starts 7am so if your kid is the
kind of kid that thrives at midnight
then there's no room for them they have
to kind of be tired in school in that
sense i think we're not really doing a
good job in creating a world that aligns
to us we're lying to the world yeah and
i guess just for me
just to i'm just feeling like
this over pathologizing of like the per
it's taking me so long to get out of the
perfectionism of like you have to eat
this and work out this much and sleep
this much i'm kind of just like you know
what i'm just gonna
i'm gonna have coffee at five if i want
to i'm not i'm not gonna not look at my
phone for four hours before bed you
fucking dork so i think what it's gonna
it's so much more stressful for me to
wake up tomorrow to 900 texts because i
didn't check my phone for four hours so
that i could sleep eight hours now you
know what i'm saying
it's just like a lot of time a lot of
these solutions to me are way more
stressful than just doing it the quote
dysfunctional way all right so i think
this is a great message to have like so
so you know some people are caught with
life that doesn't allow them like if you
have like a kid but you have to be
there's a name and so on but as much as
life allows you i think it's a great
kind of
innovative idea to try to remove for a
second the kind of rules and say okay
like what works for me i think that what
i recommend people to do often when they
ask like you know ceos and come in and
say help us figure out our brain and so
on tell them forget for neuroscience for
a second for the next week write a diary
as in every time you make a choice a
simple or a big choice write the choice
options that you had and the conditions
so say okay i were in a restaurant and
there was like a offering of steak salad
and salmon
those are the three options
and i was with my friend and it was cold
and i was a little bit depressed you
write it down and you make a choice and
then you move on with your life you wait
for another week and then you look back
at the diary and you say okay the
assignment that i chose in the
restaurant i'm happy with give it a plus
one the
choice to leave for work at six a.m and
being late was a bad one so you just
kind of scroll them a little bit after
and you start seeing what's common to
the choices that you like and what's
going on you don't like and that's
something everyone can like can do so
say okay you know what i'm every time
that i'm with the
iron i feel good so maybe stick keep er
in my life every time i make choices at
midnight bad you start without kind of
having looking at the brain you can
already feel that there's something that
everyone can do like just look back but
keep a diary yeah if you think that
you're gonna remember if you think that
you know yourself you don't i want
people to have a listen to that and they
write down right now this is a thing we
have to you know help people take
messages good one it changes your life i
mean just like a journaling overwhelms
me because i'm too much of a
perfectionist and i'm like my
handwriting's not good today and and
when this is in a documentary one day
it's gonna look bad so here's a chance
for you to actually you know get
someone's neurolink takes you thoughts
i'm giving all the credit they're far
from that but neuroscientists will
take your thought and like at some point
just based on your inner thoughts a
diary is gonna be written and you can at
least have access to one version of you
that is true like you don't have to
filter it at all
how nice would that but then doesn't
that kind of debunk the placebo effect
on stuff like are we going to lose the
placebo effect because
the whole thing is like we have to kind
of lie to ourselves
and if neurolink is going to be what
we're actually thinking are we not going
to be able to
like manifest and
it's going to change so now the question
is like are we attached to the reality
we have right now so much that we don't
want to change it are we willing to so
we will lose some things that we have
right now and maybe we're going to maybe
that's okay so i think that that's their
approach
so dreams that's not right
um
i have a prepared segment
dreams
they're fascinating
everyone wants to know about them no
matter what i speak when i give talks
people in the end ask me about sex drugs
and dreams those are the three questions
ethics sometimes but those are four
things that always come up in every talk
and it's because we're making huge
progress in the last decade
understanding dreams that we could not
make before so here's the statement
that's going to get me in trouble
freud and carl jung and all of the
researchers who started doing the camera
like they're gonna
the ones that are all the people that we
studied in kind of psychology 101 had no
access to dreams they had access to the
report about a dream that a person gave
them when they woke up so freud sat next
to our person said tell me now that
you're awake what your dreams were and
the person told them a story that was
interesting and relevant and it helps in
the therapy it's like recommended to do
this but it had nothing to do maybe with
a dream so
they have no access to dreams in the
last 10 years because of neuroscience
we're able to poke your brain when
you're dreaming and actually get the
visuals in the narrative of the dream
and now we have a real visual of a dream
not your story you can take the a
picture of someone's dream there's a guy
in japan yuki kamitani
in the
holy cow those are the two 2013 they had
the first paper where they had a person
go to sleep when the person's asleep and
they get to the stage where they're
dreaming they recorded activity from the
occipital lobe basically the part of the
brain that sees visuals and they kind of
could pass the visuals of the dream so
let's say they present and then does the
guy wake up and corroborate it yes then
they wake him up they they intentionally
write them up right when i say tell me
what you think of the person says i saw
text or i was on the beach with someone
and there were sunsets and like you kind
of you have them tell a story and you
see how often is the story that you're
telling aligning with what you predicted
they were gonna tell before and if it's
not aligning you also can tell them look
you say that you were with your best
friend on the beach what i'm seeing is
you reading a book and the person says
oh yeah this makes sense oh oh no but
it's also interesting to see but that
can't be powerful because i'm also the
bitch who like i remember like i i fully
i happen to have one right here i fully
kind of believe that um
sonogram pictures are all fake
like i literally i mean i remember when
i like first saw when i was like oh they
probably have like 20 of them
and they just
do what i'm saying like i'm reading
every sonogram photo i see looks like i
feel like i've seen that one like i feel
like you guys have a couple that you
rotate and there's no way that machine
is really fucked up inside this is your
dream yeah like you know what i'm saying
like i'm also it's the same way like the
placebo power of suggestion we can't all
of a sudden like just completely forget
about those when
so there's an answer for it but wait do
you know what the guy who said that
birds are fake you know this thing
okay
like this person yes that's so funny
they did it so this so this kamitamini
research in 2013 is building on a
different work by a guy at berkeley jill
garant and what he did is he did the
same thing without sleep so he just took
your so you're whitney you're subject in
the study you come to the lab
we sit you there we put an fmi machine
next to you so you're kind of lying in a
huge magnet and then you're watching
movies so you're watching movies and we
know which movies you're watching while
we read from your productivity the
visual areas can i ask you a stupid
question what motivates someone to
participate in one of these studies
the money in the in the particular one
that i mentioned they get it's like the
wheel people it's undergrads at berkeley
that get paid 25 to sleep in the lab
okay i'll sleep the sleep one is in
japan the berkeley ones are students
they come you tell them we're gonna pay
25 and you're gonna sit and you're gonna
watch movies that's all they do so they
sit and watch movies and what happens in
their studies is that like for the first
half an hour they're watching movies
that we tell them in advance are the
ones they're going to watch so they see
i don't know the pink panther
came up and you see a two bro girls and
see whatever we kind of planned and it's
like five-minute segments of movies and
we know which movies are watching and
we're looking at their brain and when
they're looking at this particular movie
we know what's the visual on the screen
and we read from the productivity the
kind of
changes in
bald it's like how much oxygen is in
part of the brain but we say okay when
he's seeing a blue thing this spot
lights up so this part is responsible
for blue things and when he sees a green
thing this spot lights up so it's
responsible for granting so for the
first time experiment they watch things
that we know and we just see what parts
got them then we start showing them
movies that we don't know so we say
randomly go to youtube watch a movie all
we do is we look at part of your brain
that we looked at before and now we see
that this part lights up this particular
list but lifetime we're going to guess
which movie you're seeing so you don't
tell us which movie you're seeing we're
just going to look at the part of your
brain and we're going to read the movie
from the occipital
imprint and however accurate we are we
say we're good in reading brains
that's a study so this is the awake
version of that it allowed them to know
that we can actually read from your
brain using fmri it's pretty crude
machine the thing that you're seeing
with your eyes now different groups that
close your eyes go to sleep you're still
seeing visuals we're gonna read the
visuals and we're gonna say okay the
movie that you're saying right now in
your brain is a movie that has this
thing this thing this thing and then
we're gonna wake you up and we say hey
what do you think your dreams are about
let's see how good we are i can never
remember my james
okay so now the question that we're
gonna get to next is like okay so what
are dreams for if
if if they afford something can i tell
you what i thought
like i just love telling people that no
way the scientists are going to have six
years and they're battling
and when i started a new psych drug like
a new depression drug my dreams got so
much more vivid i remember them in such
detail whereas i didn't before i was
there
your dreams are wild why is that i
so the one drug for dreams is the
ibogaine it's like all about that like
you're asleep and you basically stay
awake and you're so you're dreaming
that's the one from the tree
yeah yes it's a plant from gabon yeah
but you have to it's it's not ayahuasca
but it's like in that it's in the
category but it's not it's all it's
about is basically you still sleep and
wake up but what doesn't sleep is your
consciousness if you go to sleep you're
still awake so the dream happens and you
say okay now i want to
i don't know see my grandmother that i
didn't see ever in my life and she shows
up and because it's your brain conjuring
the image
it's as real as it gets so you think
it's grandmother and you can ask her and
she would speak in what you think is her
voice but actually it's your brain
making but you actually have a
conversation with her so if you want
closure with your mom that you never had
because i get to write their lines or do
they get to just say what they want your
brain gets to write their line but it's
not really your conscious like you don't
really know what they're going to say
like you're surprised even though it's
you manufacturing them it's really
useful for i mean so it's not used at
all right now as a therapy but in a way
it could because it allows you to get
closures on things that you can't do
it's like the ultimate vr right when you
put vr goggles in the real world right
now and the monster comes and gets can
you do this it's over but is that a
little bit of a like i don't know for me
it's like is that something
is it that humans need we need to figure
out a way to get them closure or we need
to figure out a way to live knowing
there's certain things we will never
have closure on you know like for me
it's like i just like
like surrender is like has been the key
to me not um
just being a panic attack all the time
like yeah wars just happens like shit
sometimes great people die too young and
like that like like no amount of closure
is gonna
so seven cents before like we don't know
we haven't we've never had the other
world where we get to fix problems fully
like i feel like we say we need closure
just as a way to like see our ex again
and restart shit do you know what i'm
saying this this i just think it's kind
of a mirage that like closure is going
to help us
heal so that's just me no so it's it's
not the kind of ultimate solution like
it's not like that okay like you said
about your mom dying and we bring mom
and five minutes with her is gonna be
that's all you needed yeah it it could
for something i need things to have been
different when i was a kid
it's a little bit harder
but we have to change memories that
would be a little bit
more kind of different approach but the
dream approach is actually not kind of
it's not tested so we don't know but it
seems not like a bad idea to give people
a chance to bring back someone who died
and have a final conversation with them
or even you know what i would want to do
you know when you like
like fight with someone or you're in an
altercation with an ex or something
or i'm sorry you're in an altercation
with and you think of a good comeback
like a year later
and you're like i don't want to get back
together with that person i just like i
just figured out call the current
boyfriend and say like if he ever says
that say this yeah
it's totally totally like that's what i
would use that technology for but
imagine how good it is like now you can
have a dream and in the dream you're
playing this scenario and he says you're
a lot and you say this thing and you see
him getting that's brilliant how could i
not that's a beautiful movie to make in
your mind every night you could sleep it
would every every bit of closure would
end with them proposing and me being
like no
i'm good i have closure let's just do a
little more cause i really want to get
the the dream stuff in okay because
there were six right so um that's one
dream one six there's six theories see i
can go there in the comments but okay
theory one two the first two how bad the
the second three are great the bad ones
basically say that dreams don't exist in
versions of that
one shows that they really don't exist
it's one experiment where you go to
sleep and someone plays the symbol next
to your dreaming brain and you wake up
kind of frantically and say what's going
on and tell you quickly tell us your
dream and you say
uh i was walking the street and there
was a huge explosion so far it makes
sense the symbol makes the sound and
then i looked to my left and i saw a
building collapse so i went to the
building and i saved the baby but then i
saw puppy that you said you basically
tell an entire story that's all starting
with the sound of the explosion which
suggests that you didn't really dream
any of that you just woke up you had a
big sound in your
ears and you made up a story entirely
upon waking up that's gonna fill the
gaps
theory one dreams don't exist and we
just make them up
as we wake up by whatever we had in our
mind put it aside no one likes this
theory
the number one theory is out number two
is similar it says basically dreams are
our brains fragmenting itself so
memories are scattered in the brain and
overnight the brain sorts the memories
it just puts them in buckets and
organize them so they move around and
our brand sees kind of movies and says
okay let's make a story on it and you
make a story but they mean nothing it's
just like a
it's your brain's filing exactly like
you see the filing happening and you say
oh i see one paper with this one paper
this i guess they connected so let's
make a story of it but then how would
like i um sarah silverman has that funny
joke about like i had a dream about a
shark with braces it's like you didn't
see that you know like all the stuff
that's like crazy
exactly so okay yeah so that's the
theory alan upson is the guy he
basically says dreams are our brain
moving things around make a story none
of that happened the story doesn't make
sense and there's no point waking up and
telling ford this story because it's not
going to solve anything it's just like i
had memory then you moved around second
one that we don't like the third one
that's
nicer but still kind of not giving us a
lot of meaning is one where dreams are
our brain's way of
uh
pre
saving territory real estate so here's
one of the things like
when you're when you're dreaming your
occipital lobe the part of the brain
that interprets visuals is not working
because there's no visuals your eyes are
closed so it's just sitting there
dormant in many people when a part of a
brain is not doing stuff other parts
start taking over if you know like blind
people have this thing blind people they
don't get inputs into their criminal
lobe so the auditory context takes over
and usually they have better hearing
because their
brain restructured and gave the
visual parts more control over the the
auditory parts of all of the visual
parts
what the theory that i'm talking about
right now says is that when you go to
sleep you have a part of your brain
that's big that's not doing anything
because there's no visuals so other
parts would take over unless this spot
creates a visual from within it's
protected so the brain basically creates
a movie just doesn't matter what the
movie is just a movie so the seeing part
will process stuff and we won't not have
kind of activity there so no one's gonna
take over
okay three that we don't like now the
three that we do like the first one
comes from francis creek my mentor not
this guy
so he said basically the dreams are our
brain's way of
pruning memories forgetting you
basically go back to the day before you
start looking at all the things that
you've been through and you say this one
is not really important let's get rid of
it so your brain is actually to make
space to make space and to also kind of
so this is the fifth theory is the
opposite of that is that dreams are
actually always of strength memory but
it's the same thing you basically kind
of figure out what's important is there
also a case to be made if i really hope
this is true so that you know we talked
about earlier when you introduce
yourself to someone and they're like
we've met i know you and so now i can be
like i'm sorry my brain just pruned it
out to make space yeah it's not you it's
me it's just my brain doesn't think we
need it you didn't rise to the level of
information my brain pruned you out
because you were just taking up too much
space funny enough so here's one of the
things i always get asked is okay so you
know i told you i'm
given a talk someone comes after with a
question question on dreams always come
up and the number one question that
comes up on dreams is i got to sleep
next to my boyfriend and he wakes up and
tells me that he don't know about his
ex-girlfriend what do they do so we in
our life decide that dreams mean
something
and that if you dreamt it you wanted it
so if you woke up to your boyfriend and
you said like
screw you how could you turn my hair
like i said i didn't know it happened to
me i didn't didn't mind so we think that
they mean something so you so this
argument people are now trying to do do
you think i was really gonna do what i
would tell you
that's the other thing it's like i
dreamt about my hooking up with my ex
it's like how could you do you think i'd
tell you if i was really about to do it
we have this cheap that they tell you
exactly yeah exactly
so so four and five theo is four and
five that we like a little bit more or
the one that is basically when you're
dreaming your brain looks at memories
and kind of changes the weight
theory four is it mostly focuses on bad
ones and removing them theory number
five is that mostly focusing on the good
ones and trying to amplify them but
either way it says that dreams are our
way to look back in the in the kind of
the day and decide how to go forward
with the things you care about theory
six the last one my favorite one
is the dreams are our brains way of
simulating futures yeah and preparing
for we have a joke you kind of you have
this joke and you're not sure about it
and you kind of want to play it you
dream of yourself telling it to a room
full of people and you see how they
respond and even though you don't know
it's stimulation your brain actually
does its best
in creating the true environment like it
actually will say oh men are going to
like this one but women would not and
people in their 20s would not like it
but 40s would not you kind of have your
brains experiences play into those
audiences in the dream
and you come up not with their memory of
the dream itself but with the feeling of
what works so you wake up in the morning
and you might not remember the dream at
all like kevin said like she might
forget everything but you will still go
to the joke
and you say oh yeah this really is funny
like you're gonna do it and this video
is funny it's the output of you
overnight playing this stream playing i
tried it out well exactly and there are
many kind of so many times you would
probably have a dream where you try 10
different jokes and you're going to come
up knowing that this one is the best one
this one the second best and so on it
actually helps so so it does so this
rehearsal actually changes muscle memory
and it actually makes us kind of
calibrate i hand move it better we do
get better yeah by rehearsing the movie
that we're the style of yeah yeah like
which is like when i had this really big
performing thing i had to do recently
night like when you play it over in your
head over and over and over again before
you actually do it i always
like
but um is there also anything to that it
is how we prepare for scary uh dangerous
scenarios so so in this idea also lies
the fact that like you're about to go
hiking and as birds theirs like where
you're gonna be there are bears you
actually will in your dream if it's in
your mind and you wear that you will
actually see the bear and you will
pretend to make some noises and run away
and sound and in doing so you created in
your brain a root of action so tomorrow
when you see the bear you will actually
have a better chance of fighting it or
doing the right thing because you dreamt
about it rehearsed it and you're good
but then there's like in in my dream the
bear was cool like this is that what if
you prepare the raw i'm saying so so
taking now a little bit science fiction
approach but we actually are playing
there so so you know 2015 that the first
study that showed that you can actually
redream happened since then we did a lot
of mode that we actually now read dreams
in a better way and much nicer way one
of the things that playing with is
actually narrating creating dreams for
you so you go to sleep and you say
tonight i want to dream about the bear i
wanted to be mean and big because i'm
preparing for something that happens now
and we're going to give you the dream
that you want wow with the experience
that you asked for so you can prepare
for that so we're going to do that
that's step two step step one is to read
step two is to write that's wild and
that's kind of you know if you think
about like your industry the that's the
kind of first step towards the idea that
we can actually start giving you just
dreams as entertainment like you know
you
give you one example oh my god it's
literally that's gonna happen like just
book to show when's it on it's actually
one of the ones where people are
sleeping
like i just got a tv show the one catch
is that it's only on when you're
sleeping
like i just booked a show
i think the ceo of netflix is called
saying something that like he's the
biggest competitor for netflix is asleep
this was like his quote that he got a
lot of like bad press for who was it the
ceo of netflix oh rita yeah okay he said
like
like because we said like we already won
the battle against other but we still
people are still sleeping not watching
what things we're going to do something
about that oh that's oh i wow that is
wild so you got a lot of bad press for
that but in a way that's now solving
that netflix just does netflix awake
netflix sleep you kind of buy the you
know go to sleep and say i want to drink
my spielberg please and you go to sleep
and you get like the perfect dream i
think it's i think there's there's bad
things about it but also cool things
like yeah no that's that i'm into that
i'm sorry
bring your boyfriend and instead of just
like retiring into your sleep separately
and each of you kind of has their own
dream you can agree that you're gonna
activate the machine at the right time
and you're both gonna dream about a trip
that you're gonna do together so you
wake up in the morning and you say how
was your journey how was your journey i
saw you this is a nice outcome of like
dream incubation we call it
like why don't we spend more time with
we have
like we slept we had a i mean that's i
mean that you want to go to mars with
your boyfriend they didn't go to maus
right mouse is house for you to get so
okay say let's tonight and dream go to
maus and tomorrow morning you can tell
me what you saw in mars and how romantic
was it for you and i'll tell you how it
was for me now it's a really nice
experience for the two of you that is
like another level of like workaholism
like i need shit to get done in my sleep
like i can't go down there hold on
there's a couple more questions i'm just
really quick how does luck change your
brain
so uh generally i think that uh
people that
are given luck tend to think differently
i give an experiment i'm gonna do such a
bad job doing it in the show time here's
the experiment
you and i play monopoly okay you come to
the eleven people tell us in advance
you're gonna play monopoly the two of
you but before you wanna play starts
we're gonna have different rules for
this game this guy's gonna go like that
one of you we don't know who it is he's
gonna be the rich person that is going
to be the poor person
the least person gets two thousand
dollars they pull two hundred dollars
then each person it throws two dice and
they kind of move faster in the board
they pull only one the rich person every
time they go they pass through go gets
again 2000 and the poor guy only 200 the
rich guy doesn't go to jail ever so kind
of we make it very clear that there's
inequality there rich guy and poogai and
also we're going to give the rich guy
half the boat to begin with
this experiment was done they're being
put together they tell them this thing
and then they say we're going to throw a
dice now and decide who is going to be
the rich guy who's going to be the full
guy ah
so one person is assigned to be the rich
the other person assigned to the poor
and now they start playing obviously the
rich guy wins
by a landslide quickly they kind of take
over so that's unsurprising what's
surprising is that within minutes from
the moment the game begins there is a
guy who was assigned to be reached by
luck
starts internalizing that they're rich
and smart and start giving advice to the
poor guy so you know you shouldn't have
bought this trailer this is the mistake
you made and the poor guy also starts
pretending like actually taking said
yeah i made a mistake so both of them
within minutes
forget that they got lucky and you know
got a million dollar when they were born
upon the dead like they think they
earned their places
and they totally forget that there's
luck there and their brain now starts
cementing this approach that i'm good
i'm a smart investor i'm really kind of
knowledgeable about something and same
goes to the pool guys we immediately
start thinking i'm not really good in
this in that sense being lucky
changes your brain because you start
telling yourself a story that says i'm
not lucky i deserve it and that i think
was the kind of the the
bonus for if you are lucky but also the
reason we should kind of be aware of
that because it means that we telling a
story that is not true to ourselves and
starting to believe in it
that's fascinating because i feel like i
have the eye of imposter syndrome i have
the like this i just got this because of
luck like i don't deserve any of this i
got you know what i mean when i like
there's also i don't know maybe
i think that's a first i would say
that's the better version right the
better version is to doubt than to start
believing you have too many kind of rich
people who basically forget that no they
they get the money from an inheritance
and that's why they started so i think
the better version if i were to choose
is to constantly say i
might be lucky i might be unlucky i
might be kind of getting it
unfairly i might be like those those the
skepticism is it may be the best version
of brain therapy right right that's
that is why it's your instagram sentence
oh my god do we use 100 of our brain yes
common mis myth is that we don't it's
like saying that pianos don't work
because you only use some keys at a time
the piano yeah
and you don't use them all at the time
but you all
get used
your phone
uh
so it has good things let's start kind
of like you know keeping the the people
who clearly happy it's not great for the
brain
it affects negatively our memory it
affects negatively our but isn't it but
it's not just what evolution is like
we're evolving to need
to remember things less because we can
always look it up we are the tools of
our tools is the quote by some kind of
philosopher that i like yeah like we
hear that those tools we can't take them
out
and they're now controlling us that's
going to be here forever we can do our
best to work with it the the so if i
were to choose one thing
to avoid i would say that there's kind
of debate about cancer and if it's
causing cancer so that's that's for
clinical i would say the one thing that
is
important is that
of all the things that he does that we
don't like the one thing that actually
is important is the social life so if
you if you if you spend so much time
with the phone that you don't have
interaction with humans that's that's
when it becomes too bad but other than
that
that's what it is but like
you're saying the emf thing that it
doesn't cut the phones don't cause
cancer like from the radiation but i
guess
you could argue that if your phone is
stressing you out and that's emitting
cortisol
that is bad for you yes i think the one
study that was done and there's many
studies but the one kind of
thing that everyone argued was that
phones cause cancer they put it here and
they have glioblastoma this was not kind
of verified in anywhere but i said the
bad news is that even for that when for
one week it came up as if it's true for
one week there was like a headline
phones cause cancer not a signal
changing people's buying phones they
wouldn't that's the thing right now
right now if we said it doesn't well
cigarettes like no one that cares like
people are fine hurting themselves if
they're getting those hits everything
that worked for cigarettes and four
other things i'm a little bit like
trying to help companies in the
government find ways to change behavior
the only thing that seemed to work is
social so of cigarette campaigns nothing
works like putting like a big sticker
that says it's going to kill you telling
you it's going to kill nothing but the
only thing that worked a little bit was
telling a secondhand smoking telling
people that they kill others all that's
that so if if your phone is going to
kill me then it's going to start and
then also other people shaming you like
it used to be like cool and sexy now
it's like get the fuck out of here
you're killing my child and then uh
that's interesting and then in la i
remember when they first instituted that
you can't smoke inside the idea of like
having to go outside alone and not be
able to hang out with your friends and
by the time you come back you're going
to like not
you're lost you're like miss some inside
jokes it's like the so being like
socially ostracized so of all the things
those are the things that somewhat work
like like the social aspect of shaming
maybe does mine was like seeing um like
the vanity like yellow fingernails and
then they say you get more wrinkles
around your mouth and i was like well
i'm not doing that
not because my lungs just wrinkles
around the mouth that's what i had to
hear what's more important yeah
what is the main motivator in people
that you find like
so i still think that happiness is a
driver for a lot of people very rarely
do they achieve it but this is something
that people kind of would say and i
think that the negative one is trauma
like bad things so people so if you ask
how i would change behavior like people
ask me out during corona how do you
behave and so on turns out that the
bad things are helpful
not negative reinforcement yeah like you
get you you know like you try to get an
addict to stop i don't know drinking you
have to have a rock bottom yeah rock
bottom is a really good way to do that
not recommend it but it's working it
really it that that is by the way i mean
but that's so liberating to hear for
everybody that is like frustrated by
addict's behavior in their life it's
like you just have to wait for them to
hit that rock bottom and make it it has
to be and we always say the we hit rock
bottom and keep digging but it has to
just be so bad that your attic brain is
like i nothing is worth
so here's what i said okay so the
negative we got rock bottom
is a way to change behavior
generally the social interactions are
the positive version so we can do a lot
a lot to help people who are addicts by
creating a social environment there's a
there's a famous study from the 80s
the one with the uh it's it's a it's a
study that kind of paved the road
forever to saying that the drugs are bad
and now it was reversed and said that
there's a way to deal with it so here's
the study in like very fast uh
description they take a mouse and they
basically have two livers in the womb
and one liver gives food and one liver
gives it a zap into the vta eventual
segmental area the part of the brain
that gives you orgasm pleasure full
pleasure like addiction the politics
melina i don't know what that is i've
never experienced one the pilot is
really kind of happy like when you have
i don't know like a really great
experience this is the part that lights
up pleasure center in your brain so the
uh
rats not mice i think it was rats then
that sits there and it has the option
every minute to push one lever and get
pleasure or food those rats died of
starvation because they just kept
pushing the pleasure center the same
place the center that activated by
heroin and many many good drugs this for
four years was the hallmark study to
show that drugs are bad for us because
here is an example people would kill
themselves just to have this pleasure
about five years ago
the same guys who did the study did a
version of it that
flipped a result with a play pen exactly
to hang out there's like no three
options like
food drugs or at some point there's a
theme park of other rats where you can
go play with them most threats five
times gets the reward six times you say
okay no food no you word i'm just gonna
go play with my friends this study in a
nutshell paved the road to a lot of
people saying there is a way to take
people who have had bad experiences and
help them which is give them an
environment to survive in portugal
applied that study into their entire
drug kind of thing from like the worst
country in terms of drugs in the world
they became the best as in they take
convicts who were drug addicts had bad
experiences when they go out of jail
they make it so that they're integrating
society very fast they would pay your
employer so that they both can pay you
so you're gonna have a job works magic
so there is a positive
rock bottom bad social life good
as long as the people aren't whack like
that's the other thing like it's like if
the you know it's i think that i get
frustrated sometimes when it's like well
you just have to like hang out i'm like
but it has to be the right because i for
the longest time i was like kept
struggling with checking out and doing
the whatever self-soothing behaviors and
it's like i guess i'm just socially
awkward i guess i'm just like social
link guysing doesn't work for me because
i'm just being judgmental i feel
misunderstood i feel like i feel
depleted it's like oh
it just can't be anyone i think you get
a good job like you have community
created it took me a long time to go oh
this actually is a solution for me i was
just surrounded by toxic people for
longest time because i attracted that so
it that's why it didn't work for it like
if that's not working for you just
change the people you're around to not
be
uh make drugs a good idea i agree people
they can they it's not just anyone yeah
people around you oh they think that you
should spend most time choosing um oh my
gosh there's so much deja vu oh my gosh
there's so much but can i just really
quick we were talking about death in the
beginning okay i don't really i'm not
afraid of death is that weird no i
thought i don't think about it
so it's it's not
it's not like a common but it's not
you're not the only one there's a study
on death that basically faces people
with their death and we see that many
people shut down part of their brain
when they see what they did is they
basically show you a picture and then at
some point they flash a picture of you
being buried it's like this and people's
brain must be shut down they couldn't
take it however there was a group of
people about 10 who totally kind of they
saw pictures and they saw their own
death and it was another picture so you
know among ten percent not zero but then
again at the same time i do believe the
um is that ernest becker the uh book the
worm at the core about terror management
theory that like basically everything we
do is just to manage our terror because
we know we're gonna die like just the
way that we like distract ourselves the
way that we need accolades and awards
and and family shields like the way that
we have to like make ourselves um
uh like immortalize ourselves with
trophies and shit so here's the cool
part ready
2019 just before the pandemic the study
comes out that shows that we can now
start playing with death and uh
maybe prolong life a bit after you die
so here's what they did in the study
this is a nature 2019 i'm pretty sure
does anyone look at the news now like i
want to live longer
it's just a weird time to want to live
longer there's a this community is a
after me all the time like i get emails
from them daily people who have a you
know okay how can i
replace my body and stay longer then i
get i get yeah yeah yeah
the people who want to live longer
they're they really want neuroscientists
to help them yeah so the study looked
like that they took a pig it was a pigs
took pigs that was slaughtered in a
slaughterhouse at let's say noon so the
pig is dead at noon and what they do as
soon as the pig is dead they extract the
brain and put it in a basically
incubator they feed it with nutrients
they use circulate blood they kept the
brains
of the pigs alive and the pig is already
dead
and what they showed instead is that not
only can you keep the brain active in
thinking for hours in this case after
the biggest data but also that you can
actually accept information you can
actually kind of zap out of the brain
and it responds if you want so you can
essentially communicate with the dead
pig's brain after it's dead
so you can imagine
us doing a trust with humans so you know
you die at noon and we basically take
the bodies okay whitney version one is
dead but in the tube here in the
aquarium we have whitney still with us
but will the brain be like i'm fucking
dead what the fuck why'd you do that
that's funny like i didn't have a good
day he doesn't know who you're the
body's dead
so i feel like there's got not gonna be
a lot of conversation that's not about
like what the fuck i'm bad why are you
asking me like
the brain knows yeah it was dead i mean
who knows it's big but like totally
talking about it fucking kill the rest
of me fuck this i i cannot see that
being like a normal useful thing like
grandma's same conversation
why didn't you stop me from dying why
the fuck are you asking me all these
questions
where were you when i had the gun
yeah exactly yeah that's
i
i watched this documentary about life
after death and one of the big
arguments for that something exists
after death was that someone could die
on an operating table and there'd be
absolutely no brain activity but they'd
be aware of something happening in the
room so i guess that means that's just
their same i mean so so clear this only
pigs only one study this is all now kind
of what we can do but it made scientists
really start imagining like okay like
can we you know imagine like sherlock
holmes book like you you go and you find
a dead body and you kind of instead of
saying like let's find who it is you
just ask the body like who killed you
the butler thank you let's go there's
like a this is like the shallow council
book oh
oh you know someone dies and you say who
do you want the money to go to right
like you didn't write the wheel we can
ask you so there's some kind of nice
thing about it right now the the most
the coolest and and weirdest
thing that people play with is using
dead
people's brains so to speak for tasks
you basically have the brain do chores
for you so you kind of i mean the cells
are really boring but like you basically
there's a there's a task that a lot of
people are carrying interested in which
is uh
classifying images even in death you'll
be working
i mean if you guys make my
dead brain or live brain
images
i swear to fucking guys dog cat cat dog
that's it and is that what like
billionaires are just gonna have like
nine brains like just in their house
like working for them
so see i i i i feel like we're
adventuring science fiction i'll tell
you so so one of the studies that a lot
of people are playing with right now is
a trading sleep so i said that sleep is
important and he said i don't want any
time so one question that we ask is like
i can download your sleep basically you
can sleep for me
yeah poor guy is gonna have like nine
people and you're gonna work tirelessly
that night for people that you pay will
sleep for you that will be it's not so
it's built on the idea no this i can get
behind
i for sure need a woman to carry my
child and have my like i'm so so just
also kill them so they will also
classify pictures for you like i would
get yeah and then sleep for me i mean
that is
i need that can you bank sleep
so
so okay so so the banks so essentially
you you cannot
to an extent so so if you
if you can sell your sleep emily's gonna
be the richest person on the planet if
you slept if you like were awake for 24
hours and you're really tired and then
you go to sleep and you slept for a few
hours when you wake up the day after we
will still know that you didn't sleep
night before like it's not like you pay
and you get it back and you move on like
we still would for a few days we will
still know that you're the person who
didn't sleep like it's not really bad
i'm gonna take a red eye or something
like i'll sleep for two straight days
before my red eye then i won't need to
sleep that night or day like i feel like
my body saves it but that could be a
placebo effect like if you think that's
true that could be true
so i think i think you know i said so i
said no because i wanted to be clear so
you you benefit like if you didn't sleep
for 24 hours and you slept for 24 hours
you not back you're not it's not at zero
right but you're not like a minus your
minus two like so
the body kind of uses that and
i've never had someone actually doing it
in advance like kind of sleeping before
i know more people kind of say well i'm
not going to sleep tonight but i have
more that's more firefighters have that
like they work 24 hours and then they
sleep
and for those firefighters we typically
know that they didn't sleep like we can
find their brain after they got
supposedly back to sleep and it's still
not looking great a few nights of good
sleep it's gonna come back but for a
while it's not like one to one um okay
what was your thing you're gonna end on
because i have to do stand-up tonight
okay
nice but since you're in town more we'll
do we have to do round two we will i
have so many questions so this is my uh
i i finally figured out how i end my
talks
my academic talks and uh
it addresses all the things we spoke
about in one story
and the
story um
is a story about galileo from 1616
400 years ago where he looked at the
moons of jupiter and tried to figure out
how they orbit and figured out that the
orbits of the planets of the of the of
the moons on the around the planet based
on what he saw on his telescope didn't
align with his equations
so there are many ways to solve it but
the one he chose that was
the most provocative because it was
religious was to change the entire
making of the solar system
so he believed like many people at the
time that the center of the galaxy is
earth and everything around around it
and essentially by figuring out it the
only way to explain the equation is to
put the sun in the center and earth as
the third planet i thought i was in the
center
so exactly my point
in the second was that he took a leap of
faith and he was able to change
everything and it worked for him and it
worked for us so he didn't really work
he had to lose his eye for that but like
for us it worked because in the 400
years that followed we were able to
because of this new
map of the universe we could see fun
out there into the world and explore
much more and understand the world in a
better way
the analogy is that in the last decade
neuroscientists are giving us a similar
way of looking at our own brain we're
beginning to realize that even in our
own little head
there are many voices many entities and
the one that speaks for them the one
that we think is me the one that we
cannot attach ourselves to is probably
not the most important one it's earth
and the sun are other things in our head
that don't get a lot of attention
because they don't have a voice but they
decide who we're going to love what's
going to make us sad how we're going to
make decisions in the future what we're
going to dream of and so on and in many
ways
the fact that we can now
uh
change the
working of our brain and say we're going
to suppress a little bit the
the one that gets all the attention and
give room for the others to elevate
themselves
will allow us to understand the most
interesting thing in the universe which
is us
the end
oh
so all the things i wrote in that is
that i think that in our brain this is
my message to the world i think in our
brain we have a lot more voices that
don't get to speak and the best kind of
lesson to people right now is to find
ways to give those other voices room
and that i think we're gonna actually
get better version of ourselves don't
need neural links to expose those voices
we can do it by
some other methods that are useful as
well
do you meditate
i don't like it but i do so
like it's boring for me it's so fucking
boring yeah i'm so glad you said that
okay i'm obsessed with you you know i'm
obsessed with you um
next time i want to talk about your
trick because i want you you're
antarctica trip and you're he takes a
month off a year just to be like a
person
and to like do something we're in this
month right now
in this month right now you're catching
me in right now it's so i'm here while
so from here i'm going back traveling
whoa so this was the two weeks in we
haven't stopped to see you
i'm obsessed with you
okay hey where can we find you besides
all your ted talks and your do people
have to take your classes in order to
i i have something for you
i think that you're doing a great job
communicating science and being
scientists here and so on you have a
huge platform a huge audience
find a way to incorporate science like
you know maybe have like a scientist do
the
pre-show or something like i really
think that my ask for you is that like
that i think that the ish
you made this movie and you were on the
path to do that you built the throat and
so on i think that i think that
you're doing a good job you should do
more of that thank you
well i feel bad asking
important scientists like you to come on
the because i'm like i don't want to
waste this person's time or like i don't
but it is
i think yes but i think people are so
distrusting now of doctors of uh
journalists of news it's just like
scientists i feel like are just this
the only thing that can soothe this
chaos yeah corona did really good for us
everyone now loves like the people
cheering us on the street you go back to
hospital and people like drum like i
think i need a really good scientist
it's the only time i don't feel crazy is
when
scientists are talking i was in israel
and rabbis said don't go to go
come to the to the synagogue and the
scientist says don't go and everyone
stayed at home the people actually
listen to scientists i think it's a good
time for scientists it is
yes it is and i also like comedians but
um okay so but okay there's
your ted talks i'm just gonna kill you
if you keep talking with you okay i love
you i know i have to go okay bye we'll
do it again
[Music]
um
[Music]